So, ich habe gerade auf die Uhr geguckt, mir ist aufgefallen, wir sind ja eine halbe
Stunde früher als sonst, aber das macht nichts, ich kann jetzt schlecht den Stream wieder
ausmachen, das macht ja auch keinen Sinn.
Eigentlich noch ein bisschen früh, aber wenn wir gerade dabei sind, lasst uns mal schnell,
eine Sache machen, die wir eigentlich jeden Sonntag machen, aber die Woche gucken, Moment,
ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob es neue Issues gibt, ja ich mag gar nicht, ok, GitHub Trends,
mal gucken was es diese Woche gibt, die letzten Wochen muss ich sagen, sind die GitHub Trends
wirklich doof, zumindest für mich, weil es besteht aus ein bisschen Krypto Zeug, AI Zeug
und davon halt zum größten Teil irgendwelche Chat-GPT Dinger, ich finde das Thema nicht
komplett uninteressant, aber in der Menge, es muss noch nicht jedes zweite Projekt irgendwo
was, was Likes bekommt, beziehungsweise Sterne bekommt, irgendwas mit Chat-GPT zu tun, ok,
das ist ein Projekt, ich habe keine Ahnung, Rare and Exotic, was sind denn Sets, mit Krypto
Zeug, ok, ja, weil wir auch klein, weder ist es AI Zeug oder Krypto Zeug, natürlich,
langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig,
irgendwie ist man nicht gesund, auf jeden Fall!
chat gpt chat gpt
ja war zeug ich nicht bittorrent klein okay den gibt es aber auch schon lange
also ich muss ehrlich sagen die trends waren auch schon mal spannender
mag vielleicht daran liegen dass mich in der aktuelle ai hype auf github ein
bisschen kalt lässt ich finde das thema jetzt nicht ich sage jetzt nicht dass es
so überflüssig ist sie sollen sie mal andere aller repos machen können ja schon
machen aber mich interessiert es einfach nicht in dem maße wie star repos gibt
ab klok 8 36 aber hier poggers unternahme ich glaube das liegt daran weil du genau
bis 70 wie supporter so was genau das geht aber auch nur wenn man die passende
passende adult installiert hat leider gibt so was nicht normal auf twitch
wäre schon cool wenn man beispielsweise auf twitch auch den usernamen
customisieren könnte und so was auf der anderen seite ich verstehe warum twitch
das offiziell nicht macht weil dann wäre der ganze chat vielleicht deutlich
schlechter lesbar wenn alle wenn alle namen über die namen sind jetzt schon
unterschiedlich schon unterschiedliche farben aber dann alle namen quasi auch
noch so farbverlaufsmäßig werden vielleicht wollen sie es deswegen nicht
ansonsten machen die ja alles was sich irgendwie monetarisieren lässt
teleport teleport ist das die geschichte mit irgendwas mit ssh tunnel ssh tunnel
und configs mit mitnehmen auf den server irgendwie sowas ich habe irgendwas im
hinterkopf ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher gerade was es ist
die können sich wieder nicht entscheiden wie laut die playlist sein soll
wir können mal gucken teleport github was es jetzt war
go oder ist es written in go selbstverständlich könnt ihr nur noch
getoppt werden mit written in rust sehr rauchseitsche für den sub
mir das habe ich noch nicht benutzt
die read me vermittelt mir jetzt auf den ersten blick auch nicht so wirklich so
mal in einem besatz was es eigentlich ist es ist irgendein gateway für
verschiedene remote technologien also entweder ndp ssh oder sonst wie das heißt
man braucht ein interface für alles klingt ja nicht schlecht
es kommt darauf an was du machen wirst selbst bei htps kann doch mein provider
sehen welche seiten ich anfrage ich bin mir da immer nicht so hundertprozentig
sicher was man jetzt bei htps alles sieht und was nicht
htps ist ja im prinzip so quasi über tls also das ist so eine mischung aus aus
irgendwie aufsatz auf tcp und und was eigenes da gibt es ja irgendwie sni
geschichten wo man hin will ich glaube du siehst es weil du unverschlüsselt den
den ziel host übertragen muss genau genau da kommt es auch noch auf die
version an dem wobei der header der header ist der header ist schon immer
verschlüsselt oder du hast ja wobei wobei nicht er hätte also den host
musstest du glaube ich den host konntest du glaube ich früher sehen weil du ja
dem surfer erstmal mitteilen möchtest muss wo du genau hin willst also wenn du
wenn du es ich glaube sni hat nennt sich das du musst ja quasi dem dem dem
gegenüber erstmal sagen wo du genau hin willst das heißt du hast glaube ich
gesehen den host anteil aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob du die komplette seite
gesehen hast das müssen wir mal mit weihrauch gucken das bringt mir aus
kopf jetzt und unschlüssig was du alles genau was du alles genau siehst
allerdings muss man mal sagen also ein vpn schütze ich auch jetzt nur zum teil
davor dass anbieter mitkriegen was du machst weil also da gibt es gibt es
mehrere punkte als erstes du musst dann auch wirklich also wenn du nicht willst
dass ein internet provider was sieht oder zumindest nicht so offensichtlich
dann musst du auf jeden fall sicherstellen das ist gar nicht so
einfach dass nichts am vpn vorbei geht dass nichts liegt am vpn vorbei also
du musst dann zum beispiel auch deinen kompletten traffic stoppen sollte das
vpn mal down gehen du musst da du darfst nichts übertragen
bevor dann vpn aufgebaut ist es muss auch ja alles auf jeden fall immer über das
vpn gehen also auch dns anfragen alles möglich also gar nichts zu liegen ist
gar nicht so einfach das ist das erste und das zweite ist letztendlich kann
dann vielleicht ein internet provider das nicht sehen aber irgendein shady vpn
provider oder ist halt die frage ob dir das lieber ist gut wenn du jetzt sagst
ok der du machst da irgendwelche dinge in der grau zone
du willst lieber dass es irgendein vpn provider mitbekommt der dann vielleicht
nichts aufzeichnet immerhin das sagen die ja auch nur ob das letztendlich so ist
wenn es hart auf hart kommt ist dann auch wieder fraglich ob dir das lieber ist
dass es der vpn anbieter weiß als dein provider ja ok kann man kann man machen
der eigentliche anbieter wo du dann allerdings letztendlich den service
benutzt der kann dich ja nach wie vor tracken also ein vpn schützt sich auch
nicht davor dass google und microsoft und facebook und und twitter und alle
möglichen dich irgendwie tracken das ist egal
es ist auch egal ob du den tor browser verwendest je nachdem wie du es konfiguriert
hast ja also die tracken dich ja eh nur sekundär über deine ip und solche
geschichten die tracken dich hauptsächlich über cookies oder aber
über irgendwelche browser fingerprint techniken die auch immer ausgefeilter
werden da wurde dann wirklich sogar einzelne rechner und einzelne user
identifizieren kann selbst wenn du die gleiche ip benutzen sowas das ist
tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach wie man sich das vorstellen mit
privatsphäre ich meine spätestens wenn du dich
irgendwo einloggst bei einem service ist es eh vorbei weil dann weiß zumindest
dieser service schon mal wer du bist weil du hast ja eingeloggt dann kann er das
auch zuordnen zu anderen logins also wenn man wirklich anonym sein will dann
muss man auch viele komfort funktionen also einbußen in komfort funktionen
hinnehmen ja du musst zum beispiel sagen wir mal du müsstest den browser
verwenden du gehst immer über vpn oder tor und du müsstest dann auch jedes mal
beim browser schließen alle cookies löschen und solche geschichten was kaum
jemand macht weil niemand den ich je gesehen habe ist so hardcore drauf was
das angeht und möchte sich jedes mal bei allem neu einloggen oder neu
customisern oder irgendwas eintragen
da muss ich einfach überlegen ob man das ob einem diese art von anonymität das
ist was man haben will ob es dann einfach nur andere anbieter weiß oder ob das einem
überhaupt was bringt dass es sein internet provider nicht weiß und
ansonsten vpn sind schon sinnvoll aber vpn finde ich sind gar nicht so sehr
sinnvoll für diese sache von wegen wie sie immer hier groß beworben wird so
alle tracken dich im internet deswegen musst du ein vpn nehmen da bringt dir
nämlich meistens in vpn auch herzlich wenig dagegen das bringt halt für so
sachen wie ich will netflix in einem anderen land gucken oder vielleicht
vielleicht für den ein oder anderen er sagt ich will mir per tor und was
runterladen was was was nicht nur sicherheits kopien sind von einem selbst
dann dann ja warum nicht ja dann kann es schon was bringen
aber für die meisten ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sinnvoll wie
man denkt
dns anfragen kannst du eh sehen dns anfragen haben wir mit https und tls
nichts zu tun da müsstest du schon dann verschlüsselt
dns sachen verwenden diese mittlerweile auch gibt und spätestens seit es dns
über https gibt gibt es ja auch noch nicht so lang ist das ja auch eine
möglichkeit aber das ist ja was andere also die kannst du in der regel sehen
das kann sein wie gesagt es kommt auch immer ein
bisschen auf die auf die tls version an allerdings ja genau bei encrypt dns
nicht allerdings hast du ja oftmals so einen gemeinsamen nenner dass sie dann
doch nicht das neueste verwenden ja dann okay dann ist es tatsächlich so wie ich
gesagt habe ganz den host auslesen aber du kannst
ich dir den fad auslesen was ja auch sinnvoll klingt ist ein vpn über ein
raspberry pi anonymer wie gesagt es kommt immer darauf an welche art von
anonymität du haben willst wenn du jetzt zum beispiel bei dir daheim in
raspberry pi hast und dort kein an wire guard drauf und du willst dass man in
öffentlichen wlans weniger von dir mitbekommt dann kannst du das machen dann
ist das sinnvoll anonymer dass man es dir zuordnen kann wird es auch nicht weil
es geht ja daheim immer noch alles über deinen internetanschluss
ja browser fingerprinting ist mittlerweile richtig advanced
wisst ihr ich habe letztens ich habe letztens in artikel darüber gelesen
irgendwas glaube irgendwas auf hacker news verlinkt ist wird das gewesen
sein die sind die die browser fingerprinter sind mittlerweile ganz
also vielleicht noch mal kurz als denke was versteht man unter browser browser
fingerprinting das klingt ja erst mal ein bisschen wir damit ist gemeint dass
man verschiedene user identifizieren kann anhand der eigenschaft von ihrem
browser also man erstellt quasi einen fingerabdruck für den browser da gibt
es verschiedene möglichkeiten wie man das machen kann
früher das geht jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr so einfach früher hat man zum
beispiel installierte schriftarten genommen und so geschichten also sprich
welche schriftarten hat der jeweilige rechner installiert und das war schon
relativ nicht unique aber doch konntest du zumindest gut zu an den windows mac
linux und dann vielleicht auch per customize dann aber schriftarten geben
wir die browser in der form und weiß er gar nicht mehr raus kann sie gar nicht
mehr abfragen aber mittlerweile ist das richtig richtig
advanced wisst ihr habe ich letztens habe ich letztens im artikel gelesen was
gerade was gerade angesagt ist um ein browser finger also ein teil davon
browser fingerprint zu erstellen und zwar das sind emojis
da kann man sich jetzt natürlich fragen ok was haben immer wie tragen
emojis dazu bei dass man einen browser eindeutig identifizieren kann er
emojis haben verschiedene eigenschaften und zwar also warum das warum das eine
gute sache ist emojis haben verschiedene eigenschaften zwar die sehen
unterschiedlich ausschauen mal je nach plattform das heißt wenn jemand das
emoji analysiert was dein browser malt dann weiß er schon mal sehr sicher auf
welcher plattform du unterwegs bist und nicht nur windows mac linux sogar die
emojis unter windows 10 und windows 11 sehen anders aus
er weiß auch beispielsweise ob du mozilla verwendest oder was anderes also
das er erkennt daran schon mal ohne probleme die plattform und höchst
wahrscheinlich den browser wenn er sich einfach nur die emojis anguckt die dann
browser malt so und dass das malen der emojis passiert ja dann halt auch über
irgendeinen wegen canvas oder webgl dann weiß da schon mal ok du kannst 3d
beschleunigten content darstellen oder nicht und der kann dann auch analysieren
wie schnell wird dieses emoji gemalt und kann darauf rückschlüsse ziehen was du
für eine grafikkarte hast was du für eine rechner konfiguration hast so
pima daumen der kann anhand des renderings der emojis sogar noch mehr
feststellen also noch mehr was die platte was die plattform angeht also sprich
wie ist das anti-elasing gelöst und sowas also du kannst anhand von so eine
wenn du ein canvas machst ein emoji darauf malen lässt vom browser und das
emoji danach analysiert kriegst du sehr viel über die aktuelle plattform
eingesetzten browser und technologien raus inklusive rechner zusammen
stellung so ein bisschen ja also anhand eines publischen emojis können die
schon ziemlich gut feststellen wer ihr seid und dann speichern die sich das und
wenn ihr wieder auf die webseite geht selbst mit anderen ip oder über einen
vpn können die euch trotzdem wieder erkennen weil der rechner immer noch der
gleiche
natürlich ist es nicht so easy wie in 1 zu 1 direktes cookie mapping wo drin
steht ja das ist der und der user aber das ist auch schon mal gar nicht so
verkehrt und denkt man gar nicht dran ist durch publische emojis dass man da so
viel drüber raus kriegt über ein da könnte ich eigentlich mal ein video
drüber machen
so browser fingerprinting das braucht natürlich so einen schönen clickbait
titel was du nicht willst dass das ist zu kompliziert habe ich schon ich hab das
mal erwähnt aber ich habe da noch ein eigenes video drüber gemacht
ja also ihr seht es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach dass mit anonymität
im internet kann man auch selbst einen dns server betreiben ja kannst du machen
wie bekommt man wie also wie kommen die an die adresse die fragen einfach andere
dns aber
und cashen die sich dann vielleicht ja
so dieses emote kennt eine dunkelsten geheimnis auch das ist ein schöner
titel ist gefällig leis dieses emoji kennt eine dunkle ist die heim das ist
ein guter titel ich sehe schon ihr habt ihr habt ihr habt das clickbait game
durchgespielt
ich finde das andere besser
ja gut ich sehe ich selbst ich selbst gucke ja nicht
wobei ich könnte ja wirklich mal so jebait machen ich könnte ich habe ja
so eine keksmaske dass man mich eh nicht richtig erkennt und dann gucke ich so
und dann gucke ich so gucke ich so halb ins bild so mit so mit so mit so mit
einer gesichtshälfte noch liegt frage zeichnen
dann zu der stange für den sub
die freshen auf uns google noch irgendwas youtube was gescheites empfiehlt
was verdient man mit zwar das ist schon vier monate alles haben wir schon
geguckt ja weil ich mich auch so unglaublich für ist es basketball
wahrscheinlich interessiere ok youtube ist der weinung max du willst jetzt
basketball gucken aber hartnäckig und fußball weil ich auch so ein großer
fußball und basketball fan bin
du deine youtube ist ok es gibt nur eine sache um das youtube abzugewöhnt auf
machen und gleich wieder schließen dass die view time so gering ist dass sie
sicht ok jetzt haben sie geschafft
android versus ios was ist sicherer
das video ist aber ganz schön lang ich glaube das können wir jetzt heute
morgen nicht gucken
es gibt gar keine angriffe auf iphone ja das sagen vielleicht irgendwelche
iphone fanboys aber ich erinnere euch nur mal daran manipulierte zeichen über
sms geschickt schon hatte das iphone des öfteren probleme
das neue linkin park moment die gibt es noch dachte der sänger ist gestorben vor
paar jahren na gut wahrscheinlich irgendwelche aufgezeichneten
sachen von früher oder einer der sänger an den zweiten den rapper gibt es ja noch
es gibt öfters mal was auf ios wie gesagt ich kann mich nur noch dran
erinnern dass noch vor nicht allzu langer zeit und das war auch mehrfach
gab es ein problem wenn du per sms also das haben sie gefixt und dann gab es
kam wieder was anderes raus kannst du nicht verstecken emotions ist auch nicht
schlecht das war mehrfach dass du irgendwelche
manipulierten zeichen über ein message wahrscheinlich ein message über sms
oder so über per nachricht ans iphone verschicken konntest und es hat dann
rumgebackt doch gar nicht so lange her
jepp clock 9 uhr ok jetzt ist die normale zeit wo es normalerweise das
stream auch los geht
also ganz ehrlich die empfehlung von youtube war auch schon mal besser
alles nicht so dass jemand seit wann will ich ufc oder fußball gucken was
denkt was ist denn mit youtube bloß gerade macht ja überhaupt keinen sinn
gehört null zu meinen sehgewohnheiten ok warum das 9,4 millionen aufrufe hat
das liegt bestimmt nur am tischtennis glaube einzig und allein am tischtennis
legt es und nicht an anderen sachen safe also die youtube empfehlung ist schon
teilweise extrem bewegung ich meine das meiste geht in ordnung das könnte man
sich eventuell sogar anschauen aber einiges da drin wo ich wieder was will
mir youtube sagen custom spaceship gaming room ok das ist irgendwie ganz
nice ok reingehen reingehen mit das bescheuert also reingehen mit so einem
weltraum anzug müsste ich ja dann auch nicht das wäre dann schon wieder zu
umständlich
excellent leute exquisite jetzt geht's los jetzt geht's los endlich das muss
jetzt sein leute wir gucken uns jetzt kurz eineinhalb stunden bethoven an
exzellent ich bin da mal afk
iq steigern so also leute was haben wir denn hier zeigt mal her samsung wie
früher jetzt nicht die harte realität als software entwickler wirtschaftsinformatik
studieren das erste mal kundenkontakt oje das ct wie die überlinungs des
tops haben wir uns schon angeguckt
warum ist denn das unten an wirtschaftsinformatik das erste mal kundenkontakt leute
kundenkontakt ist das letzte was man als IT mensch haben will ok das sind ja
wirtschaftsinformatiker die studieren ja aber nur wirtschaftsinformatik weil
dann mathe nicht so schwer ist also viele haben mit wirtschaft dann auch
nichts zu tun haben sage ich jetzt einfach so change my mind
intern versus amd wer ist besser ein tag als software entwickler im büro alles
klar tarif bei was verdient man als verkäufer ok komm wir gucken uns jetzt an
was ein was was der wirtschaftsinformatiker sagt das video hat
der chat vorgeschlagen das heißt wenn das video nichts taugt ist ganz einfach
dann können wir sagen der chat hat müsst empfohlen warum studieren die da
nicht bvl anstatt und warum studiert man denn wirtschaftsinformatik wenn man
eigentlich bvl machen will dachte bvl ich dachte wirtschaftsinformatik
studieren die ganzen leute den mathe im normalen informatik studium zu schwer
ist sind die job sind sind die shop job chancen wirklich besser danach naja gut
wahrscheinlich weil alle stehen sie auf it ob die leute dann wirklich ahnung
davon haben ist ja wieder was anderes weil ohne ahnung wird wird sie auch
nix aber vielleicht bleibt ein bisschen bisschen was im hinterkopf hängen bei
den leuten
gut die fahren da nicht nicht ja du hast schon recht aber die fahren da auch
unter anderem darauf ab weil das ländchen jahre lang verpennt haben oder
festgestellt haben mist frage schallte leute die ahnung von von it system haben
sie doch nicht verkehrt und wenn die alle abhauen ist auch doof
ich habe vor einer ganzen weile es ist schon zwei drei jahre her habe ich den
bandbeitrag auf youtube gesehen von irgendeinem in unternehmensberater gut
gewesen sein ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau und er hat erzählt dass es
relativ viele startups in deutschland gibt aktuell dass es wohl so einen
kleinen start-up boom gab oder gibt ich weiß ja nicht dass ich schon video war
schon paar war schon bisschen älter jetzt zu heute und das liegt daran nicht
etwa weil die alle so mega krass innovativ sind und sich super neues zeug
ausdenken sondern weil viele alteingesessene
unternehmen alles total verschlafen haben die letzten jahre über und es jetzt
wohl viele startups gibt die sich darauf spezialisiert haben den ganzen boomer
leuten neue technologie näher zu bringen
also wir sind eigentlich nicht super innovativer startups angeht zumindest
ging das aus diesem beitrag hervor sondern wir sind eigentlich haben die
weil die anderen es so lange verschlafen haben
aber keine ahnung jetzt ist gut wenn der fisi microsoft
lastig ist da liegt das daran weil jeder da hergelaufene
trainer meint er ist krasser microsoft checker und davon gibt es einfach mehr
wenn du leute suchst die was mit was handfestes über linux erklären können
wird es so deutlich schwieriger fündig als irgendwelche leute so basic
es aber so wenn du leute sucht die basic linux sachen erklären können wir so
deutlich schwieriger fündig als leute die basic microsoft sachen erklären
kann es zumindest meinen erklären zu können
also ich weiß allerdings weder was ils oder sgd ist ich habe keine ahnung
wofür das wofür das steht integrated school integrated linux
ne keine ahnung also neuen ordner erstellen können reicht schon aus für
viele dass sie meinen sie können jetzt microsoft trainer werden
ach das sind fernstudium anbieter
am ende ist es doch egal wenn du dein studium abgeschlossen hast hast du das
abgeschlossen ist doch wurscht bei welcher uni das oder oder fh das jetzt
gewesen ist oder interessiert das irgendjemand gucken die gucken die
drauf also klar wenn du jetzt irgendwie dein informatik
dings mit gemacht hast oder werde ich bestimmt darauf gucken aber so da echt
die gucken da drauf also interessiert das im personaler wirklich ob du dein
informatik studium an der fernhochschule gemacht hast oder an
engländer in der fernstudium uni oder in frankfurt sagen wir mal ich gar nicht
weiß ob man das in frankfurt studieren kann
haben wir in frankfurt informatik studieren
wahrscheinlich also wirtschaftsgedöns kannst du in frankfurt studieren das
weiß ich habe keine ahnung ich habe mich damit auch nie beschäftigt ehrlich
gesagt weil ich eh nicht vor hab irgendwas zu studieren noch mal
ok ok zeige ich mal her also youtube was gibt es zu gucken was fangen wir dann an
wenn uns nichts einfällt fangen wir einfach vorne an
komm wir kommen wir können uns jetzt ich lasse mich jetzt ich lasse mich mal
abschrecken von kundenkontakt ich überlege ich überlege gerade
how to protect your linux servers vom hackers okay das können wir auch
irgendwann mal angucken kann ich mein selbst dazu geben
waffer gibt es jetzt bis 45 ok ja ich will trotzdem ich studieren
ich überlege gerade was war mein erstes mein erster kundenkontakt
fällt mir jetzt gar nicht ein also ich habe zum glück relativ wenig
endkundenkontakt ich vermute mal mein erster endkundenkontakt war dass sich
irgendeiner am telefon verwählt hat ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr dran
erinnern aber ich kann mich an einige verwehler
erinnern weil ich hatte bei uns relativ ähnliche
durchwahl jahrelang telefon technisch wie so eine
provisions abrechnungs abteilung und ihr könnt euch vorstellen die leute die
bei der provision und bei der abrechnung angerufen haben die waren
immer eh sehr gut drauf weil die da rufst du ja nur an wenn was in der
abrechnung nicht stimmt und dann hatte ich oftmals leute am telefon da kann ich
mich auch dran erinnern oftmals leute am telefon die du hast den hörer
abgenommen und die haben nicht gleich versucht anzuscheißen da muss ich sagen
ne ne mehr hätte sagen dass wahrscheinlich sind sie so wütend dass
sie sich vertippt haben aber sie sind falsch falsche letzte stelle bei der
telefonnummer ich kann dazu überhaupt nichts sagen
die waren die waren teilweise bisschen gereizt
in welchem bereich der it würde ihr empfehlen zu arbeiten kurz vor master und
keine panne wenn ich mir also wenn du kurz vor master bist und du musst doch
eine ahnung haben was dich interessiert oder also die mutti du musst doch zu
kroben vorstellung haben was dir gefällt
wenn du gar keine ahnung hast dann würde ich da weil dann kann man ja auch
nicht sagen welchen bereich man jetzt empfiehlt weil man weiß ja nicht ob es
wirklich was für die sicht würde ich jetzt dann nehmen den arbeitgeber der
dir am besten gefällt entweder der die am besten bezahlt der am nächsten dran
ist oder der die einfach aus irgendwelchen gründen am besten
gefällt wenn du eh keine ahnung hast was du genau machen willst
nimm den arbeitgeber den du am besten findest
das ist schon anders als wenn du studierst aber das den themen als
themenbereich was dir gefällt wirst du im studium so ein bisschen mitgekriegt
haben programmierst du gerne machst du gerne eher frontend backend sachen
machst du lieber theoretische sachen die backst du gerne irgendwelche komplexen
automatisierung steuerungsdinger keine ahnung mein irgendwas ja aber welcher
theoretische mist gefällt mir am besten also ansonsten wenn ich wirklich gar
keine ahnung habe wenn du wirklich gar keine ahnung hast da neben das wo sie
den arbeitgeber die beste arbeitgeber findet
die oma hat auch immer relativ viele verkehrte anrufe falsche anrufe gekriegt
ok gucken wir uns das mal an also wirtschaft informatik studieren das
erste mal kundenkontakt wobei ich ja sagen muss ein hauptsächlicher punkt
warum ich was mit computer mache ist damit ich nicht so viel kunden
beziehungsweise endkunden und end user kontakt habe oder generell nicht so viel
kontakt mit random leuten habe vor allem in noobs die keine ahnung haben
deswegen arbeite ich ja in der it ich will möglichst wenig mit unterschiedlichen
leuten zu tun haben
ok also guck mal ich muss die lautstärke einstellen
so ich nur noch nicht mehr so kenne ich bei mir nannt sich ist der geringste
anteil an arbeit es gab nicht so viele intensive moment ok und dann kommt er mit
solchen uren und ich denke mir so kann ich nicht problemieren an sich ist der
geringste ansteuer ein bisschen hat er jetzt heute erst mal der macht es
richtig leute habt ihr es gesehen der macht es richtig
erst mal stack overflow öffnen exakt so geht es halt einfach in der realität
was will er keine ahnung stack overflow auf in zukunft in zukunft vielleicht
alternativ auch noch check der guck ein bisschen ein bisschen hi ja das stimmt
schon aber gut ich mein vielleicht auch einfach zu lange auf dem rechner
gestoppt auf dem monitor gestarrt in zukunft vielleicht auch noch chat gpt und
co-pilot fragen aber stack overflow wird nach wie vor
nummer eins bleiben es kann nicht so viele intensive moment in meinem leben
die jetzt das ist einfach nur müde sein die erste dame alles gesprengt
alter noobs und dann auch noch im altersheim ohje da hätte ich ja bock
drauf nicht studiere wirtschaftsinformatik an der fbs aktuell
schreibe ich meine bachelorarbeit hier mit der karitas zusammen seit ungefähr
zwei wochen und heute ist der erste tag wo ich den kontakt habe mit meinen
kunden den signoren ok er guckt auch schon als hat er überhaupt kein bock
drauf was ich voll ganz nachvollziehen kann ein mehr generationen haus ok was
ist ein mehr generationen aus leben da die rentner und studenten zusammen so
studenten brauchen billiges billige unterkunft und rentner brauchen irgendwie
zuwendung ansprache und bisschen unterstützung oder wie darf man sich das
vorstellen was ist was ist ein mehr generationen haus da heute getermined
ist wichtig weil ich bisher noch keine berührungspunkte mit dem endkunden
oder wie kann ich irgendwas entwickeln wo ich den kunden ich kann oder es
funktioniert das funktioniert gar kein problem also man muss ja glücklicherweise
selbst den endkunden nicht kennen
ein system entstehen welches den menschen im altnamen erlaubt die
nachrichten der angehörigen zu empfangen dabei ist die eine
voraussetzung dass diese system möglichst einfach zu den nachrichten von
angehörigen ich meine es gibt 30 milliarden messaging systeme
ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gesagt das ist ein gelöstes problem aber nutzen
ist mein ziel ist eigentlich bei dieser projektarbeit für meinen kunden schmackhaft
zu machen und die haben am anfangt klar bedenken im 2 schickt so den brief oder
den fax ich aber auch nehmen damit sie im endeffekt bei meinem projekt mitmachen
und mir auch ehrliches feedback geben können
die seniorin sollen was moment
die seniorin sollen die videos ihre angange auf einem tablet ja dazu gibt es
doch 30 milliarden fertige apps also ich will nicht in frage stellen
dass man dabei viel lernt wenn man sowas selbst macht wenn das das ziel ist
selbstverständlich kann man machen sollte man machen um was zu lernen
praktischen zu mehr wert unterm strich wird es wahrscheinlich nicht bringen
weil ich bezweifle dass man mal kurz in seiner in seiner abschlussarbeit was auf
die beine stellt was von der infrastruktur und ja der app
funktionalität in allem rankommt an der etablierte etablierte anbieter
also aufgeregt bin ich nicht vorbereitet sagen wir mal zu 85 prozent
video download und alles verwaltung funktioniert alles auf der laptop
rufe ich die domäne aber von meinem tablet aus auf funktioniert die
website an sich aber die domäne die videos werden nicht abgespielt
das gute ist ich bin vier stunden vorher da deswegen habe ich zeit
aber die musik mann du denkst wunder gleich gleich kommt james bond mit dem
auto durch den hintergrund gefahren das ist gestern hat geklappt heute willst
nicht okay das ja das der default also die
letzten tage waren sehr von koffein und t schwarz und t durchdrungen also ich
muss mich sehr viel informieren wie was funktioniert welche technologie nicht
benutzt was macht er würde mich mal interessieren wie er das macht macht
er diese web rtc gedöns oder wie funktioniert das das wird mich bei
solchen videos manchmal okay ich gebe zu den normalen youtube den normalen youtube
zuschauer interessiert wahrscheinlich nicht so aber mich wird es tatsächlich
interessieren was er da genau macht voll ist wie ich das umsetzen kann
allgemein das war schon intensiv also ich sag mal dass es gab nicht so viele
intensive moment in meinem leben wir jetzt
in unserem studium lernen wir sehr viel software anwendung das heißt
irgendwelche berechnungssysteme irgendwelche datenbanken oder
irgendwas programmiermäßiges aber mit der hardware machen wir eigentlich
nichts so und dann sagt mir mein prof erst mal erst mal eine runde esp 32
auspacken kronen nachrichtendienst ja an sich schon okay ja klar damit kann ich
was anfangen und dann kommt er mit solchen uren und ich denke mir so kann
ich nicht genau also für mich war es komplett das neuland so mikrocontroller
und allgemein so was komplett krass ungefähr ablauf soll so haben sie
irgendwie rausgeschnitten angehörigen also die leute die was senden wollen im
endeffekt an der next cloud instanz die hosten dort laden sie videos hoch und
die angehörigen bekommen irgendeine art von signal dass sie ihn zeigt hoch
nachricht und haben die möglichkeit dieses video wann immer sie werden
ab so ein abzuspielen
warum brauchen die da für nur ok weil das ist projekt cooler macht i guess ja
ich lese einfach mal so sachen durch und dann liest und liest und schaust dir
gegebenenfalls noch teuer wie das an und liest noch mehr also man liest hier sehr
sehr viel problemieren an sich ist man hat permanent der gov offler dass das
will das soll so sieht die realität hat aus ja der geringste anteil an der
arbeit
ich muss ja wenn ich die applikation fertig habe sie noch mal an die leute
bringen ich muss sie analysieren mit use cases und so weiter und dann schauen
ob sie sich das ist eine abschlussarbeit also im endeffekt ist es nicht so dass
das langfristig benutzt wird
die videos kommt nicht auf die uhr die nachricht das meine ich doch deswegen ist
die uhr eigentlich relativ überflüssig die nachricht das neues video vorliegt
kommt auf die uhr
aber leute über 70 haben überhaupt keine probleme mit mit tablet bedienung
wenn man das ihnen alles mal ein bisschen gescheit nahe gebracht hat meine
mutter ist jetzt glaube ich 71 oder so weil es gar nicht genau 72 glaube ich
und die benutzt den ganzen tag ihr tablet fast ausschließlich ihr tablet
hat noch irgendwo nordburg das hat sie glaube ich seit drei jahren nicht mehr
angehabt oder so nur tablet tagein tageaus und und ja ihr smartphone
auch wichtig wir haben aspekte von wirtschaftwissenschaftlern also
rechnungswesen ko und halt noch diesen informatik aspekt mit dabei und versuchen
das zu vereinen damit die beiden gruppen müssen sich miteinander austauschen
kann und deswegen hast du eine relativ breite zu wissen was du dir aneignen
musst aus meiner erfahrung heraus kann ich sagen dass die wirtschaft informatik
an langen atem brauchen irgendwo hast du eine stärken und irgendwo halt nicht das
stimmt wohl
ja aber das chat ich gebe euch ja recht ja schreibt jemand viele aus der
generation haben halt einfach keinen bock auf den kram aber wenn du jemand
hast aus der generation der kein bock auf dem kram hat der macht dann auch kein
ich kucke mir videos in nextcloud an oder ich kucke mir videos auf dem tablet an
der sagt dann den scheiß will ich nicht die leute sollen vorbeikommen oder
sollen mich anrufen also mein opa mein opa hätte auch kein bock drauf gehabt
mein opa wäre glaube ich dieses jahrhundert geworden
kann das sein
ne
ne kann nicht sein ich habe doch mal ich habe doch mal ein video mit meinem opa
hochgeladen nachdem er gestorben ist wann war das denn 2012 2012 vor zehn
jahren nee ich glaube mein opa ist gestorben mit
88 oder so
nächstes jahr oder nächstes nächstes jahr wäre glaube ich hundert gewonnen
ist mir gerade eingefallen
ich habe die kunden ich habe immer alle ich habe die ganze interaktion hin und
her und die ganze terminierung das ist schon ich habe noch nie so viel
terminiert wie in den letzten wochen
sieht auch schon mal ganz schick aus was was was was sind wir sehend
login
sie
seg und
was
logins seg seg seg seg second page ist es second page einfach falsch
geschrieben keine ahnung
ja gut schick schick kann man sich jetzt holen ich gehe mal davon aus das ist so
groß gemacht dass die rentner das easy bedienen können
sieht auch schon mal ganz schick aus ist alles noch relativ unglaublich
prototyp mäßig gebaut das eine ist natürlich diese technische
herausforderung noch viel schwierigere ist eigentlich diese fachlich soziale
oder auch augenringe oft du mal herausforderungen zu meistern und da so
zu bauen das ist für die leute eben auch funktioniert das projekt wird eine
open source anwendung bedeutet so viel wie nach meiner fertigstellung kann
eigentlich jeder den codes einsehen und ich fände schon irgendwo cool wenn die
leute dann irgendwann durch meine bibliothek vielleicht mal durchforschen
und sagen wir hatten der das gemacht wie hat er das umgesetzt oder das ist
eigentlich alles dafür sind diese projekte auch tatsächlich gut das heißt
irgendjemand das folgt eine krasse anwendung für sie eher nicht aber für
sowas sind solche projekte tatsächlich sehr nice dass man sich einfach abgucken
kann wenn man was bauen will wie wurde irgendwie was gemacht das ist meiner
meinung nach eben eigentlich mit die größte quelle wie man was lernt man muss
sich angucken was andere gemacht haben also egal jetzt ob programmier sprachen
lernen oder so wie benutze ich library xy wie löse ich dieses problem am besten
ist man findet was wo jemand was ähnliches gemacht hat oder vielleicht
auch das gleiche gemacht hat vielleicht auch in der anderen sprache gemacht hat
und guckt sich an ok wie hat der das denn gelöst oder kommt man dann ganz gut
dahinter und lernt einiges also code von anderen leuten source code sich angucken
von anderen leuten ist das sehr praktisch dass das heutzutage so ohne
weiteres möglich ist ja auch und auch zu finden da geht haben die so ein leichter
dritter schlag irgendwie cool
und bedenkt man den man denkt ganz viele sachen und dann sind so ganz stumpfe
dinge wo du denkst also der typische der typische pep kack moment problem exist
between keyboard and chair freestylen eigentlich gibt es immer im mittleren
wege wie irgendwas funktioniert wo muss ich halt nur finden
tatsächlich habe ich programmieren eins beim zweiten mal geschafft beim ersten
mal bin ich durchgerasselt weil ich falsch gelernt habe habe ich es zu leicht
genommen und habe die ganzen übungen am laptop gemacht und der zweite mal habe
ich wie es eigentlich empfohlen ist mit stift und papier geübt es klingt immer
ein bisschen abstrakt aber es ist wenn du halt einen informatiker background hast
in der jahrzeit doch schon wirklich gut weil du verinnerlicht halt die ganzen
datenstrukturen wie du was definierst da kam dann so sachen wie wie wird der
binary tree in wörter wie er allgemein die schreibweise ist ja und implementiere
eine linked list und solche dinge kommt dann habe ich es geschafft mit zweiten
mal so eine scheiße es läuft jetzt alles über mein händchen
all der falle was für ein kram so jetzt wird mich mehr nicht dem ersten dem
eigentlichen probieren
zeit läuft ab jetzt ein bisschen stressig
das gute ist er reagiert aber nicht so wie ich will
was mich wundert ist was ist der unterschied ob er dort jetzt sitzt mit
seinem tablet und notebook versus er sitzt daheim mit seinem tablet und
notebook also ok vielleicht hängt er beide bei sich
daheim im wlan und da gibt es keine probleme und dort im wlan wenn er das
wlan von dem alten heim verwendet haben sie kleint isolation oder sowas oder
isolation oder wie auch immer man es jetzt auch nicht an und deswegen kann er nicht
sich die die geräte nicht erreichen aber wenn er seinen eigenen hotspot macht
sollte es überhaupt kein unterschied machen
und auch störungen so ich meine das ding liegt direkt daneben
habe ich kaufmann gelernt kaufmann manson handel aber im laufe des der
ausbildung aber gemerkt glaube im zweiten lehrer war das der kam zu die
ersten selbstbedienbaren kassen so in die testphase ich weiß nur dass ich mir
dann gedacht habe ja der beruf automatisierbare im endeffekt also
außerdem ist es ein beruf der mich übelst abfacken würde aber gut ihr
wisst ja ich habe auch mal ein bisschen bvl zeug gemacht und hatte keinen bock
mehr drauf wenn die technik soweit ist wegrationalisiert für mich war das
einfach nichts mehr und dann habe ich mich als gefasst und
habe mir gedacht machs halt mal weiter und habe mein abitur nachgeholt
ab der uni hatten wir einen wirklich wissenschaftlichen ansatz also wirklich
theoretischen ansatz in der fahr haben wir eine komplette kehrtwende also was
du hier an basics für fürs programmieren für software entwicklung
oder für andere gebiete halt im lernst das das waren die tatsächlich fast aus
der aus der praxis raus also aus der direkten anwendung doch das werden wir
auch lieber mit arbeiten
ich habe mir schon gedacht dass wir gehalten haben das werden jetzt nicht die
heiler sein ja ich habe ich habe einfach gehofft dass die schon mal ein tablet in
der hand hatten und dass sie auch dafür offen sind
hat kein bock
im endeffekt mache ich eine applikation also ich mache ich was zum teufel ist
eine applikation da geht es schon los
mache ich mache ich ein programm womit ja das kann ich mir vorstellen das ist
echt nicht einfach sich angehörige mit ihnen zum beispiel einfach austauschen
können so ganz grob gesagt warum sollte ich so was benutzen die
können mich doch auch einfach anrufen da haben wir uns gedacht dass sie haben
wir diese tablets so genau und mein program würde einfach einfach auf ihrem
tablet einfach hochgeladen werden irgendwie und dann könnten könnten
ihre angehörigen einfach ihren nachrichten auch drauf sprechen sie
würden benachrichtigt werden und können sie nachrichten und dann abhören
wie eine einbahnstraße alles nur von ihren also von ihren kindern enkeln
die machen das nicht die die machen das net bedeutet übersetzt ich habe da kein
bock drauf die will ich sagen ich will den scheiß net also aus ihrer sicht ja
gesagt die machen das net das weiß ich okay die erste dame die hat auf alles
gesprengt ich habe glaube ich kaum ein wort rausgebracht das war schon mal ein
sehr guter auftakt aber damit hat sie im endeffekt mir die möglichkeit geben sie
zu überzeugen
hätten sie generell zu engst oder so einfach mal
beispiel ist mal ganz grob gesagt so was zu benutzen einfach so eine uhr
kann die kann die uhr auch neben hinlegen die hatten gyroskop und so
weiter drin ein gyroskop ja alles klar da wissen die oma ist natürlich bescheid
was gemein ist moment sensor mit dem sich der genaue standort
bestimmen lässt wait a minute ist die ist gyroskop nicht
lage und neigung und so was
moment da muss ich jetzt nachgucken
drehbewegung messen oder beibehalten ja ja genau
und ihnen auch signale zusenden irgendwie vermitteln nicht okay ich habe
irgendwie von allen kundentypen irgendwie alle dabei gehabt jemand das
ablehnt und jemand das will und ich kann damit dann jetzt der opa fände es
bestimmt cool ist auch cool da ist neue uhr kunden orientiert arbeiten und dann
auf feedback warten und schauen was wie sie was sie dann zu der software sagen
wenn sie fertig ist werden sie dem auch aufgeschlossen wenn sie wenn ich ihnen
zum beispiel jetzt nach weihnachten ein prototypen geben wird
den sie mir so ein bisschen antesten
die begeisterung die begeisterung ist zu spüren
ich will es mal mit meiner tochter probieren ich weiß nicht wo ich das
hinlegen soll oder hinhängen soll das ist bei mir unmöglich die will ich die will
ich ja das merkt man auch gleich das merkt man auch gleich gerne kein bock
so man der ok kann ja jeder machen wir aber ich finde es immer witzig wenn die
leute sich rausreden mit also dass die leute keinen bock haben
also das trifft ja aber weitem nicht nur auf alt zu das macht ja jeder so das
macht ja jeder irgendwie in irgendeiner situation macht das so dass man dass das
dass die leute nicht sagen habe ich keinen bock drauf gehen wir weg sondern
dass sie sagen aber dafür habe ich keinen platz ach das kann ich nirgendswo
hinlegen ich kann mir das nicht an arm machen
ach meine angehörigen verwenden das eh nicht weißt du so irgendwie einfach nicht
sagen ich habe da keinen bock drauf sondern sich so irgendwas aus den
fingern saugen warum das eigentlich eh nicht geht
gut ist irgendwo auch verständlich vielleicht
weil weil wenn du sagst will ich nicht versuchen die leute dich zu überzeugen
wenn du irgendwie so sagst ach das geht nicht aus dem und dem gründen dann
dann muss man dich ja gar nicht versuchen zu überzeugen und du hast
schneller ruhe vielleicht deswegen ja aber jetzt hatte ich das überhaupt nicht
das vertrauen und die erste alle das ist ja mini das zimmer
überhaupt nicht das vertrauen und die erste damal mein ganzes ding gespringt
uns im nachhinein ja glaube ich habe ich sie überzeugt die fahrt an der mitte
doch die was heißt überzeugt die hatte wahrscheinlich kein bock mehr die hat
wahrscheinlich am ende gesagt ja ja komm geb's her und lasst mich in ruhe
schon so erpicht das doch mal zu nutzen haben sie noch irgendwelche fragen
die hat sich gedacht ich nehme das jetzt der typ ist so hartnäckig dann habe ich
wenigstens meine ruhe ich leg's nebenhin und werde es nicht einmal benutzen 100
pro so wir das laufen ganz okay ich war versucht dass die
applikation auch auf den tablets laufen zu lassen
es war mir einfach in der kurzen zeit dass da ist irgendwas schief gelaufen
wie es halt so ist aber ich wollte mich mit dem kunden austauschen und wissen
wie die funktionieren oder bevor sie angst haben und das habe ich jetzt mir
auch festgehalten und dementsprechend liegt es eigentlich ganz gut also ich
wünsche einen schönen tag noch dankeschön
alle zwei drei wochen also jetzt habe ich zumindest auch eindrücke wie die
zimmer sind weiß ich wo das positioniert werden könnte ich weiß wie die leute
ungefähr was sie für probleme haben das war ganz interessant das kann man
sogar nicht genau jetzt wechselt er wieder in die theorie weil er sich denkt
an den endkunden kontakt für bloß weg
oh man so jetzt weiß ich auch wieder warum ich auf end user kein bock
habe und das muss noch nicht mal rentner sein was haben wir denn sonst noch samsung
wie früher galaxy s 23 ultra review ok das video wurde mir empfohlen ich habe
das mal aufgemacht weil ich ja aktuell am gucken bin was ich mir für ein
handy hole wenn meine wahl ist eigentlich schon mehr oder weniger auf
iphone 14 pro gefallen kein pro max einfach weil ich die letzten acht jahre
oder so nur iphone verwendet habe ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden damit bin aber
vielleicht taugt ja auch den android müssen wir mal gucken
ist der chat ein guter endkunde der chat ist kein endkunde weiß ich genau ob es
seine kategorie für gibt für den chat der chat ist zu high iq um endkunde sein
zu können sollte mal ein hybrid router der telekom aufbauen meine mutter und die
oma nebenan haben es nicht hingekriegt gelbes kabeln grüne bukse war schon mal
nicht richtig ja gut das verstehe ich noch irgendwo das ist so eine sache die
muss man einmal machen und dann die wieder und haben die leute vorher nicht
gemacht aber tablet bedienung und tablet benutzen ist ein ding da kann man sich
rantasten und das tag täglich verwenden und das lernt man auch wie gesagt meine
mutter verwendet nur die tablet den ganzen tag über
die hockt den ganzen tag wenn sie was macht am tablet und liest sachen guckt
im internet rum guckt sich guckt sich zeug an benutzt die eine gut manche
sachen ist noch old school ja ich habe hier schon ein paar mal gesagt hier
warum machst du nicht deine einkaufsliste einfach auf dem tablet dann sind wir
die aus handy und dann kannst du im handy hast du immer dabei und dann hast du
automatisch auch deine einkaufsliste dabei kannst sogar gucken in welchem
laden du was eigentlich nee das wird auf den zettel gemacht aber ist ja auch ok
man muss ja das ist das was ich mir denke man muss ja die leute nicht zwangs
bekehren wenn sie keinen bock drauf haben das ist auch das ist das das ist
das wo ich denke wo viele auch keinen bock drauf haben also weiß gemerkt
habe ist dass viele am anfang erst mal auf neue sachen keinen bock haben aber
wenn die sachen eine weile da sind und wenn sie die auch schon paar mal benutzt
haben dann dann dann geht es mit der zeit zum
beispiel habt ihr schon mal bei lidl mit lidl pay bezahlt wahrscheinlich nicht
gibt natürlich auch kritikpunkte dran dass man sagt ja dann kann lidl dich noch
besser tracken und sowas in der richtung aber die hatte beispielsweise immer die
probleme wenn sie zum lidl gegangen ist geld rausfüllen geld abzählen mitnehmen
alles möglichen sagen also es hat an der kasse dann teilweise richtig lange
gedauert das hatte ich auch nicht gefallen da habe ich ihr vorgeschlagen
wie wäre es denn probier doch mal aus mit der app und lidl pay zu bezahlen
das funktioniert folgendermaßen die haben den scanner an der kasse
sehen es ist eh eine webcam sehen eine kleine webcam die hängt an der kasse und
du machst dann auf deinem handy machst du die app auf dann erscheint ein qr
code in diesen qr code scanst du dort ein oder hältst du in die webcam da
machts piep und dann weiß das hat es registriert ist eigentlich total simpel
und einfach du musst nur die app aufmachen in der app auf pay drücken und
den qr code vor die kamera das war es mehr musst du nicht machen und du musst
dann du musst dann wenn du wenn du beim bezahlen bist musst du sagen du willst
per lidl pay bezahlen fertig so und du kannst juridisch auch noch irgendwelche
gutscheine in der app aktivieren und kriegst ein paar sachen paar paar euro
billiger eigentlich ist das eine ganz coole geschichte wenn man halt damit
fein ist dass eben lidl das mitbekommt ja aber lidl bietet glaube ich kein
apple pay an zumindest nicht so einfach dann zumindest habe ich ihr das
gezeigt nee warum sollte man das machen und dann dann fummelt ich lieber geld
raus so und da bin ich einmal mit ihr mit und habe das auf meinem handy gemacht
habe ihr das gezeigt das nächste mal als ich dabei war hat es mit ihrem handy
mal ausprobiert da wollte sie noch nicht so richtig und mittlerweile bezahlt sie
nur noch mit lidl pay genau du bekommst du bekommst auch die
abrechnung also da in den kastenbogen aufs handy kannst kannst nachgucken wie
das ausgegeben du hast ein sinnvolles limit drinne mittlerweile bezahlt sie nur
noch per lidl pay obwohl sie am anfang nicht wollte und gesagt hat wer braucht
diesen schwachsinn überhaupt also manchmal braucht es einfach ein
bisschen anläufe und die leute müssen selbst benutzen und feststellen ok das
ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
ich finde ich finde es ganz gut
ja das auch ist vielleicht ganz gut zu wissen
ja so siehts aus
welches tablet die hat ein ipad allerdings weiß ich nicht welche generation das ist schon
ein bisschen älter aber reicht also ist auch geschwindigkeitsmehr also kriegt noch updates
hat letztens erst ios was war das letzte keine ahnung in den ios update gekriegt also es ist
noch nicht so alt dass es keine updates mehr kriegt das ist auch schon das glaube das ist
schon das zweite tablet ne davor hatte genau davor hatte sie eine ein billiges android tablet
bis ich dann irgendwann mal gesagt habe weil das das war so abartig auch teilweise als updates
gab es ja ähnlich es hat teilweise nicht richtig reagiert beim touch auf dem touch screen war aber
abartig ja der rand war viel zu klein dann habe ich irgendwann mal ein ipad gekauft seitdem seitdem
ist gut eine sache die ich festgestellt habe bei leuten die wenig ahnung von technik haben
die denken teure geräte sind nur gut für advanced benutzer das ist aber ein trugschluss
gerade hochwertige geräte können richtig gut sein für noobs und einsteiger weil machen wir
machen wir mal ein beispiel nehmen wir mal einen billig nehmen wir mal einen billig android tablet
so ein ganz so ein ganz billiges einsteiger android tablet versus ein ipad bedienung ios
versus android kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten ich bin der meinung gerade auf dem tablet im
tabletbetrieb ist ios deutlich angenehmer als android smartphone kann man sich jetzt drüber
streiten aber ich bin auf dem tablet würde ich würde ich meinen die meisten sehen das so natürlich
hast du immer leute die alles schlecht finden und das andere dann ganz toll aber ich würde sagen
auf dem tablet ist ios schon angenehmer die bedienung ist egal allein schon die geschwindigkeit und die
reaktion versus also wenn du auf den touch screen drückst wenn du billig billig 80 euren einsteiger
android tablet kaufst hast du das problem du drückst auf den touch screen es passiert nichts
richtig das reagiert nicht du drückst eine app an es dauert 15 sekunden bis das richtig zum
ersten mal gestartet ist wo die leute dann schon die keine ahnung haben dreimal drauf geklickt
haben und dann startet das ding nun irgendwie verbackt oder so also teurere geräte sind nicht
zwangsläufig jetzt irgendwie nur für power user ich merke das auch ich höre von meiner mona
öffnungs die aussagen ach so was teures das braucht man ja gar nicht die leute denken eben
dadurch dass es schneller ist und mehr leistung hat ist das auch nur für varnste benutzer was
das kann man nicht so wirklich vergleichen mit einen opel agila versus keine ahnung irgendwie
so ein super fetten tesla oder sowas ja da kann ich da lass ich es mir irgendwie noch gefallen wenn
man sagt ok so ein größeres auto brauche ich nicht aber bei einem tablet also größeres teureres
teures mit mehr funktion brauche ich nicht aber bei einem tablet ist halt die sache die von der
bedienung ist es exakt das gleiche nur dass ich einfach das teurere deutlich angenehmer bedienen
lässt und also deswegen ist es nicht verkehrt dass sie hatten ein ipad ich die hat in halbwegs
halb ein halbwegs also neu genug ist das ipad aber die hat das auch schon jahre lang also die
nicht nur nur das klappt die man muss den leutnant mal ordentlich erklären
der gut der vorteil du hast schon recht ich müsste das tatsächlich mal mit apple pay und so aus
probieren den vorteil ist dass du es halt im lidl machen kannst im edeka machen kannst du überall
und im rewe und sonst wo überall bezahlen kannst na gut du kriegst einen kassenbon ich weiß nicht
wie es bei apple pay ist da lässt er den kassenbon zu not ausdrucken ist vielleicht
sogar noch besser wie funktionierten das ich habe apple pay noch nie benutzt muss man das
handy entsperren und irgendwie dran halten oder musst du das handy einfach nur so nfc mäßig in
die nähe halten oder wie funktioniert das ich habe das noch nie benutzt
bei beträgen er gut beim lidl ist es aber über also im supermarkt über 25 über 25 euro
doppeltipp auf den einen knopf welchen knopf rechte beim iphone rechts den zum bildschirm
sperren oder ein aus ok hast du bei dir eigentlich ein pf sens oder opensens im heimnetz nö hatte
ich eine ganze weile habe ich nicht mehr aber seit jahren schon nicht mehr ich habe meinen
mikrotik router der macht alles an netzwerk intern was ich brauche der macht für ein paar
kameras und nicht kameras für par access points macht der pw der hat eine rudimentäre firewall
regeln drauf und da dran ist dann halt auch die fritzbox muss dann die fritzbox ist dran
für woip und sonst was deckt woip zip und kram das geht da nicht drüber genau fängt
schon an wenn der bildschirm schlechten winkel hat nicht richtig regeln exakt deswegen sind
so billig geräte gar nicht gut als einsteiger geräte heia was ist denn heia bitteschön
für den hersteller habe ich noch nie gehört rb 5000 ist das der mit den antennen mit den
ne welcher das kann was welches welches normale board ist das also welches welches welcher
normale router ist das also im case die dinger gibt es ja immer als board und als case also
mit ordentlichem case drumherum was man mit dem alten ipad machen könnte keine ahnung
verkaufen gut ich meine du kannst es für offline sachen verwenden was heißt du könntest
zum beispiel du könntest zum beispiel ein dashboard machen genau so ein dashboard für
ein browser geht ja immer noch du könntest ein dashboard machen für smart home geschichten
du könntest auch zum beispiel wenn du mehrere leute leute im haushalt hast als gemeinsamen
kalenderanzeige oder so benutzen ja gibt es eigentlich gerade ich muss mal schnell was
gucken feier hd 10 gibt es sind die aktuellen eigentlich noch flaschbar
welches ist denn das feier hd 10 wahrscheinlich sind die nicht mehr flaschbar die aktuellen
feier hd 10 2023 custom gibt es da was für
ja welches fall ich glaube die aktuellen kann man nicht mehr flaschen was doofes ich
habe ja ich habe ja von vor einer weile welche gekauft die ich hier als dashboards im einsatz
habe und das ist wunderbar die habe ich geflasht alle alle beide und seitdem hängen die an
der wand nix nix mal von amazon drauf und sie tun einfach muss man den leuten halt mal
erklären gut manchmal klappt es halt nicht leider leider kannst du ja heute so gut wie
nichts mehr mit einer micro sd karte erweitern das ist taktik diese die hersteller sagen
dir natürlich ah security oder performance warum es keine micro sd karte mehr gibt der
einzige grund warum es keine micro sd karte mehr gibt ist dass die ihren flaschspeicher
zu unglaublich hohen preisen verkaufen können der speicher in smartphone ist einfach unsinnig
teuer wenn du dir überlegst du bezahlst da hunderte von euro teilweise für 128 gig
mehr dabei kriegst du eine 2 terabyte ssd für den gleichen preis fast schon hinterher
geschmissen wettgemusik ja ok was können wir uns angucken samsung wie früh komm wir
gucken uns mal wir gucken uns mal den review zu dem wir haben schon selten android zeug
gekriegt zeig mal her was was haben wir hier er wieder er wieder hey leute das galaxy s23 ultra ist ein
extreme smartphone schärfer es hat vor allem wieder so komische kameras wisst ihr das ist ein trend
ich finde es irgendwie unsinnig ich versuche euch mal zu erklären warum also der trend die
der art davor bevor die kameras so raus standen ging dahin dass man die gehäuse immer schmähler
gemacht hat was ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht fandet kleineres handy ist ja immer nicht
verkehrt so dann ist ihnen irgendwann aufgefallen ok die dinger sind so schmal und wir wollen
bessere qualität bieten und mehr linsen und alles das passt so nicht zusammen mit dem gehäuse dann
hat man jetzt die kameras einfach aus dem gehäuse raus gucken lassen das heißt warum muss denn dann
das gehäuse überhaupt noch so dünn sein warum macht man das nicht bündig ich meine würde man
wirklich damit davon sterben wenn das gehäuse jetzt einfachen millimeter breiter wäre und dafür
alles bündig weil worauf das rausläuft ist hast du eh eine hülle drum machen musst weil du nicht
willst dass der kram auf dem tisch rum kratzt und und das tablet auf dem tisch wackelt und solche
geschehen du machst eh eine hülle drum und dann ist es am ende wieder dicker also
ich weiß nicht schneller vielseitiger aber auch teurer als die konkurrenz moment noch teurer
als sind als als ein high end iphone jetzt wird es aber übertrieben ich meine ein iphone 14 pro
max kostet irgendwie was 1600 euro oder so mehr denn je habe ich mich gefragt ob sich das ganze
lohnt und für wen das galaxy s3 man bald kann sie für ein smartphone mehr ausgeben als für
den high end gaming rechner ultra ist ein wirklich großes smartphone und samsung versucht das auch in
keinster weise zu verstecken die form ist kantig und der aluminium rahmen ist das jetzt auch und
das gewicht mit 234 gramm ziemlich hoch es wirkt deswegen jetzt ist es mal wieder kantig vor ein
paar jahren wurde alles rund gemacht der edel ist aber nur bedingt ergonomisch das gleich dicke
s 22 ultra fühlt sich dünner an als das neuere s 23 ultra die einzelnen kameras ist das ein stift
ist ein stift das ist ja schon fast ein halbes tablet dann so groß wie das ist mit stiftbedienung
früher könnte ich euch noch daran erinnern als großes smartphones phablet genannt wurden
denen kameras ragen nur erstaunlich weniger vor gerade mal halb so weit wie bei apple außerdem
gefiel mir die matte beschichtung die fingerabdrücke und kratzer super abweist samsung ist der erste
hersteller mit gorilla class victus 2 das stürze aus zwei metern auf asphalt und ein meter aus
beton abhalten kann letzteres habe ich unfreiwillig getestet und ich kann euch bestätigen das glas
ist noch ganz der aluminium rahmen jedoch hat eine kleine erst mal schön runterfeuer ist untertauchen
für 30 minuten bei 1,5 meter tiefe möglich und das obwohl im s 23 ultra ein s-pen steckt dieser
besteht wie einige andere teile auch aus recyceltem ozean plastik samsung plant auf diese weise 15
tonnen plastik aus den meeren zu holen ok gute idee ich gehe aber davon aus dass es rein ein reiner
marketing stunt ist weil unterm strich wird das smartphone wahrscheinlich um ein vielfaches
mehr abfälle produzieren als das bisschen recycelt im material für diesen stift bringt und wie viel
wie viel recycelt auf diese weise verheiratetem ozean plastik samsung ultra ein s-pen steckt dieser
besteht wie einige andere teile auch aus recyceltem ozean plastik samsung plant auf diese weise 15
tonnen plastik aus den meeren zu holen klingt gut 15 tonnen ist wahrscheinlich auch wirklich gar
nicht so viel aber gut ich mein hey besser als nix insgesamt insgesamt ist es aber wahrscheinlich
trotzdem besser man kauft sich gar kein neues handy und verwendet sein altes handy weiter das
dürfte auf jeden fall umwelttechnisch deutlich freundlicher sein als ein neues handy zu kaufen
wo dann der stift aus aus dem mehr gefischtem plastik ist das ist das ist wahrscheinlich ein
reiner marketing stunt wieder von von samsung manne dankeschön für den sub dass das dass man
das halt als super grün und und sonst wie verkaufen kann das ist ja aktuell eben ein trend dass alle
unternehmen anfangen egal wie umweltschädlich und sonst was sie sind jetzt mit irgendwelchen
aktionen rumzukommen so nach dem motto ja dann pflanzen wir bäume und wir wir finanzieren ja
irgendwelche ökologischen projekte ich meine wir machen zwar immer noch den gleichen umweltschädlichen
miss wie vorher aber aber wir sind jetzt auf einmal sind wir furchtbar grün geworden jetzt
ist eigentlich alles ganz toll ich mein man kann sich jetzt darüber streiten ich meine es ist
besser als gar nix ja es ist also die können ja auch einfach gar nichts machen aber auf der
anderen seite ist es ja nicht weil sie irgendwie davon überzeugt wären dass es sinnvoll sondern
quasi das mindeste zu machen wie man sich marketing technisch gut darstellen kann und unterm
strich wahrscheinlich am ende sogar noch mehr raus zu raus zu zu zu blasen also da bin ich immer bis
da bin ich immer skeptisch wenn auf twitter oder sonst werbung kommt wo sie sich irgendwie als super
grün und umweltfreundlich darstellen wollen 15 tonnen plastik aus den meeren zu holen klingt
erstmal noch viel entspricht aber umgerechnet nur 33.000 euro ich finde also wenn samsung schon mit
sowas wirbt dann sollte ich habe das übrigens da muss da muss ich jetzt ganz kurz ganz kurz
sein muss ich jetzt eine sache noch zu sagen ich habe vor einer weile mal auf twitter geantwortet
irgendwo weiß gar nicht mehr worauf das war da ging es um das gleiche thema das könnte sogar
eine werbung gewesen sein für sowas so wir wir sind jetzt super umweltfreundlich da habe ich
auf twitter auch darauf geantwortet ja ja das einzige was sie damit bezwecken wollt ist euch
als besonders umweltfreundlich darzustellen umweltfreundlich sei trotzdem nicht oder kam
dann jemand an auf twitter und sagte max aber das ist doch egal weil wie hat er das wie hat
er das erklärt eine gute tat ist nach wie vor eine gute tat auch wenn sie vielleicht mit keinem guten
vorsatz also auch wenn sie nicht aus gutem vorsatz entstanden ist also sprich es wäre
ja trotzdem gut dass die bäume pflanzen auch wenn sie nicht den umweltschutz im sinne haben
sondern ihr eigenes wohlergehen und da dachte ich mir zu dem zeitpunkt eigentlich eigentlich hat
er gar nicht so unrecht doch dann kam das wizard game und krank da galt diese logik dann natürlich
nicht mehr da war das ganz furchtbar böse und krank der teufel da wo ich mir jetzt jetzt jetzt
jetzt können sie sich auch nicht entscheiden ist es jetzt nur eine gute tat oder ist es jetzt keine
gute tat das war dann irgendwie paradox das kannst du genau kannst du exakt genauso argumentieren
aber da zählt es dann anscheinend nicht egal jetzt gucken wir das video weiter 15 tonnen plastik aus
den meeren zu holen klingt erstmal noch viel entspricht aber umgerechnet nur 33.000 euro ich
finde also wenn samsung schon mit so was wirbt dann sollte da auch ein bisschen mehr dahinter
stecken wie zum beispiel bei nord vpn die damit werben ein sehr schneller krasse überleitung
alter ok das hat er wirklich gut gemacht die überleitung oder plastik aus den meeren zu holen klingt erst
mal noch viel entspricht aber umgerechnet nur 33.000 euro ich finde also wenn samsung schon mit
so was wirbt dann sollte da auch ein bisschen mehr stecken wie zum beispiel super das ist super
das hat er gut gemacht das perfekte überleitung vpn die damit werben ein sehr schneller vpn zu
sein und in meiner erfahrung sind sie sogar der schnellste dank über 5400 servern in über 60
ländern merke ich nicht mal wenn ich den vpn bei meinem smartphone aktiviert habe so kann ich zum
beispiel die neue the last of us serie stream über hbo max was es in deutschland ja noch nicht gibt
weil mein smartphone denkt dass es in den usa ja das kann man machen weil wieder irgendwie 30
milliarden streaming services aber nord vpn über den link sparen und vpn soll riesengroß
und dankbar ist mit die s3 bei diesem video das display des galaxy s23 ultra ist mit 6,8 zoll
riesengroß und dankbar der plus auf lösung super scharf es wird extrem hell und hat einen
knackigen kontrast und sieht oft aus wie so ein aufkleber die bildwiederholrate kann zwischen 1
und 120 herz wechseln das war beim vorgänger zwar alles auch schon so aber trotzdem ist das
auch noch ein jahr später ein sehr beeindruckendes display neu ist dass die wölbung an den seiten
deutlich reduziert wurde man sieht sie kaum noch spürt sie aber positiv beim zurückwischen der
rand unten und die selfie kamera sind zwar sehr dezent aber ich hatte gehofft dass beides im
jahr 2023 ganz verschwinden würde der ultra fingerabdrucksensor wo ist das problem warum
sollte die selfie kamera verschwinden oder meint er einfach nur dass man sie nicht mehr sieht und
dass sie noch da ist aber man sie nicht mehr sieht oder oder wie den samsung nun seit einigen
jahren verwendet ist super schnell und zuverlässig und auch besser als das was google oppo oder
schaumy verbaut unter das display also spricht dass die kamera noch da ist aber man sie nicht
mehr sieht aber seit 2021 gibt es einen nachfolger und der ist nicht nur fast doppelt so groß sondern
auch doppelt so schnell wie wo verbaut den schon eine weile und ich fände es nur angemessen dass
es samsung ihnen gleich tut was den prozessor angeht schöpft samsung dieses jahr endlich mal
aus dem vollen und das auch in europa der snapdragon 8 gen 2 vor galaxy ist was die grafik angeht der
mit abstand schnellstes markt warum vor galaxy weil samsung cool klingt prozessor auf dem markt
und bei der cpu fast ein drittel schneller als das die dinge heißen galaxy aber das ist doch keine extra
cpu jetzt nur für die oder das ist oder ist das irgendwas was extra angepasst ist für die weil
es vor galaxy ist 20 ultra dazu kommen dann noch 8 oder 12 gigabyte arbeitsspeicher der neuesten
generation die auch noch mal 36 prozent schneller ist der mindestens 256 gigabyte große speicher
platz ist zwischen 80 und 100 prozent schneller als bisher nach einem 20 minuten stresstest
drosselte die leistung um 35 prozent herunter damit liegt sie immer noch deutlich über dem
galaxy s 22 ultra ohne drosselung und diesen wirklich unerhörten performance sprung den spürt
man auch deutlich die software leute sich ja mit flüssigen sicher dass man das spürt ich muss
nämlich ehrlich sagen also vielleicht im die vielleicht im ganz direkten vergleich ok aber
ich muss sagen ich habe jetzt mal den vergleich gehabt zwischen dem iphone 14 und dem iphone
x oder so was das ist ich muss sagen ja das mit 120 herz und der neuen cpu und so im direkten
vergleich merkt es aber im alltäglichen verwenden ist es jetzt nicht so dass sie irgendwie das
gefühl hast dass ein iphone x jetzt irgendwie dich limitiert oder so also ich glaube mittlerweile
sind wir bei geschwindigkeiten bei smartphones gerade bei high end modellen schon in in
sphären vorgerückt da macht es gar keinen praktischen großen unterschied mehr 120 herz
apps öffnen augenblicklich diese komische pause untermalt von stottern die beim schließen von apps
auf dem s 22 ultra auftreten konnte ist verschwunden endlich hat samsung auch in der galaxy s serie eine
angemessene performance und muss sich nicht mehr vor apple oder google verstecken nur beim
arbeitsspeicher hätte ich gern bei allen modellen mindestens 12 gigabyte gesehen manche apps
schließen früher als das für den preis sein sollte immerhin gibt samsung richtig lange software
updates vier jahre android und fünf jahre sicherheits updates damit sind sie der markt für
ja das ist im android bereich natürlich schon absolut poggers sogar mehr als google muss man
sagen bei iphone klappt das natürlich besser die hast du teilweise weiß ich war das ich glaube ich
glaube das erste iphone se hat bis vor kurzem noch updates bekommen ich glaube das hat das hat erst
das letzte update nicht mehr bekommen das allererste iphone se okay aus irgendwelchen
gründen ist google der meinung sollte man browser ist mein browser ist broken f f für
chromium das kein bock mehr der hat sich gedacht nope machen wir nicht und geht es in dem tab
wieder geht auch nicht ok chrome ist chrome ist kaputt chrome hat sich chrome hat sich verabschiedet gut ist kein ding wir können
chrome einfach ausmachen können wieder einschalten und die tabs wieder öffnen alles ist gut aber
warum auch immer der browser jetzt abgekackt ist
iphone se das aller allererste jetzt gibt es bestimmt wikipedia eintracht zu was das
2016 und das hat bis ios bis ios was hat das gekriegt guck mal bis ios jetzt ernsthaft guck
mal das hat bis ios 15 updates bekommen das bekam das hat immer noch updates gekriegt ein
gerät von 2016 also das ist da muss man das muss man muss man apple wirklich lassen das
machen die ganz gut das sind über sechs jahre jetzt das sind das sind fast sieben jahre
man muss halt sagen ich glaube ios 16 bekommt es nicht mehr oder ok ios 16 ios 16 bekommt
es nicht mehr aber ios 15 hat es noch bekommen also muss man sich mal angucken ja und die iphone
x dinger sind ja auch schon release date sind ja auch schon ein bisschen älter ist ja auch
von 2017 also das muss man echt muss man echt mal ihn lassen sogar ein iphone 8 iphone 8
guck mal iphone 8 ist doch noch älter oder release date 2017 also da kannst du dich also
bei apple kannst du dich da wirklich nicht beschweren was was die updates angeht ok
wo sind verstehen geblieben oder man schreibt auf den spürt man auch deutlich die software
läuft rund mit flüssigen 120 herz apps öffnen augenblicklich diese komische pause untermal
auch in der galaxy s serie eine angemessene performance und muss sich nicht mehr vor
nur beim arbeitsspeicher hätte ich gern bei allen modellen mindestens 12 gigabyte gesehen
manche apps schließen früher als das für den preis sein sollte immerhin gibt samsung
richtig lange software updates vier jahre android und fünf jahre sicherheits updates
damit sind sie der marktführer sogar mehr als google selbst gibt und sie sind in letzter
zeit auch wirklich schnell geworden was die sagen mussten vier jahre für einen ich weiß
ja nicht was es kostet aber für 1500 euro oder so was smartphone warum nicht warum nicht
länger angeht was mich total freut weil das früher bei samsung ja mal ganz anders aussah
tja und auf einem galaxy s 23 ultra bekomme ich sogar noch etwas mehr software als auf
einem normalen s 23 allein wegen dem s-pen man kann mit ihm aufs display zeichnen und
schreiben er hilft auch bei besonders genauen eigentlich auf einem iphone pen verwenden
haben oder schlechte haben keine dabei aber könnte man und ich weiß es gibt smartphone
kompatible handschuhe aber sonderlich genau sind die nie und deswegen nutze ich den s-pen
im winter besonders gerne oder man nimmt einen teil des bildschirms mit ihm auf und versendet
ihn als gift datei oder man schreibt aufs ausgeschaltete display eine to do liste und
heftet sie dort an und selbst wenn ihr nicht mal vor habt mit dem mit welcher software nimmst
du dein iphone als kamera beim stream kam kameo studio dann gibt es eine app für fürs handy
und für den desktop und dann kannst du sparen und dann geht das über wlan oder über usb
macht man in der praxis nie nehme ich habe nur interessiert ob es funktioniert und dann kann
ich dann auch helligkeit und und will da wiederholrate und sowas da einstellen ist eigentlich ganz
praktisch einmal das display zu berühren hat eine pro version ich habe mir die pro version gekauft
hat nicht viel gekostet 20 euro oder so sein weil er über bluetooth als funkauslöser für die
kamera genutzt werden kann mit gestensteuerung fürs zoomen oder wechseln der auslöse modi samsung
hat schon wahnsinnig viele funktionen android 13 integriert neu ist der anpassbare sperrbildschirm
fokus modi für arbeit oder freizeit und schönere animation die optik ist zwar immer noch nicht so
ganz mein feil aber einheitlich und keine kopie von jemand anderem samsung arbeitet eng mit windows
zusammen was ist eigentlich aus dem samsung aus dem aus dem samsung assistent geworden ihr wisst
schon ich weiß nicht mal wie dieses ding hieß sam hieß es nicht sam war das nee nee nicht
samber was andere doch samsung was daraus geworden was daraus geworden eigentlich das haben die doch
auch nur gemacht dass die leute irgendwie rule 34 und irgendwelche komischen bildchen da anders
kann ich mir nicht erklären da habe ich nie wieder was von gehört und hat ein komplett eigenes
ökosystem mit smartwatch kopfhörern und eigenen trackern neben apple ist das sicherlich das
umfangreichste und die kamera hier drin die ist sogar die umfangreichste vier linsen sind es der
ultra weitwinkel sowie drei und zehnfach zoom sind identisch zum vorgänger aber die hauptkamera
hat jetzt unglaubliche 200 megapixel meine ersten bilder mit der habe ich ihnen gemischt im licht
gemacht und war ein bisschen 200 megapixel auf auf einer fläche wie wie mein kleiner fingernagel
ernüchtert von 200 megapixel habe ich da nicht viel gesehen aber ist ja auch nicht so als wären
die 108 megapixel des vorgängers jemals zu wenig gewesen doch als ich dann am tag fotografiert habe
da kam auch deutliche unterschiede zu tage was in beiden fällen ist der text zwar nicht lesbar
aber beim s 23 ultra unterschiede zu tage
was in beiden fällen ist der text zwar nicht lesbar aber beim s 23 ultra schon
deutlich detaillierter auch im vergleich zum moto h 30 ultra welches ebenfalls 200 megapixel hat
und hier mal neben dem s 23 im 50 megapixel modus man sieht jedes kleinste haar und auch
die feine texture des hems so ein hohen detailgrad habe ich bei einem smartphone
noch nie gesehen und ich finde auch die farben sind sowohl am tag als auch in der nacht wirklich
schön anzusehen es ist ein freundlicher heller warmer look die 200 megapixel bilder belegen
etwa 30 megabyte speicherplatz die normalen 12 megapixel fotos eher 5 megabyte es gibt
situationen da sind die bilder dann so scharf dass ich hinter frage ob es überhaupt noch den
dreifach zoomen gebraucht hätte der ist nämlich nur in gutem licht rauscharm und scharf für die
portrait bilder mit übrigens exzellenter kantenerkennung mag ich das etwas nähere
sicht fällt und bis sechs facher vergrößerung sind die fotos dann auch noch ansehnlich für
alles danach scheint die 10 megapixel auflösung dann etwas zu gering zu sein ab 10 facher
vergrößerung wird mittlerweile ist wirklich halbe halbe fotoausbildung notwendig für smartphones
dann wieder schärfer und es ist für mich immer noch unverständlich wieso was in einem smartphone
überhaupt möglich ist und warum es die konkurrenz bis heute nicht kopieren konnte mit dem galaxy s
23 ultra kann man den mond fotografieren oder dinge die so weit weg sind dass man sie mit
bloßem auge kaum erkennt also beim thema zoom ist samsung klar an der spitze und beim thema
video stabilisierung auch g bewegungen werden super gut ausgeglichen 8k videos mit 30 fps und
4k videos mit 60 fps sind nett anzusehen aber beeindruckende hätte ich es gefunden wenn 8k
60 fps und 4k 120 fps möglich wären die selfie kamera das galaxy s 23 ultra hat jetzt nicht mehr
40 sondern 12 megapixel sie qualitativ aber etwas besser aus und sie hat auch ein autofokus ich
finde die fotos sehen sehr angenehm und natürlich aus das ist ein super vielseitiges kamerasystem
und ich habe das gefühl für jede situation gewappnet zu sein die dynamik ich bin ja mal
gespannt was das ding jetzt kostet weil kam ja noch gar nichts zu umfang ist sehr hoch und
überbelichtung wird um jeden preis vermieden was das rauschverhalten angeht sehe ich noch
ein bisschen nachholbedarf da ist ein google pixel weiter der akku war zwar schon letztes
jahr 5000 milliampere stunden groß aber jetzt ist halt die technik effizienter geworden in
meiner erfahrung ungefähr 15 prozent und somit kam ich immer ganz entspannt durch einen tag ich
hatte sechs bis sieben stunden displaynutzung und das ist etwa eine bis zwei stunden mehr als beim
vorgänger und vergleichbar mit dem iphone 14 pro max also ein wirklich starker wert aufgeladen
wird dann mit 45 watt über einen optional erhältlichen stecker in 30 muss sagen die
akkus im vergleich zu früher sind schon deutlich deutlich besser geworden aber die
dinger verbrauchen auch mehr wenn ich das mal vergleiche mit meinem samsung handy von früher
also ich rede wirklich von früher kein smartphone handy das konnte ich quasi eine woche benutzen
dann musste ich es aufladen und heute komme ich damit knapp mal durch den tag natürlich
natürlich sind das eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr die gleiche geräte kategorie früher war
das ding halt in einem mobiltelefon mit wo du snake drauf spielen konntest das war es im
endeffekt manch einer hat wapp auf seinem handy benutzt falls ich noch irgendjemand an wapp
erinnern kann da ist natürlich die möglichkeiten heute ganz anders ist und ist auch logisch dass
das mehr allein schon die displays früher irgendwie so einen so einen schwarz-weiß monochrom display
mit quasi kaum existente auflösungen bildwiederholrate versus sowas ist natürlich versus irgendwie 4k
display mit 120 herz und hast du nicht gesehen kann man natürlich nicht wirklich vergleichen das ist
eine ganz andere gerätekategorie minuten auf etwa 60 prozent das motor edge 30 ultra schafft in 20
minuten 100 prozent und das netzteil ist dort sogar im lieferumfang obwohl es 500 euro weniger
liefer netzteile bei apple gibt es ja glaub nicht mehr die haben ja gesagt haben die haben ja keinen
bock das teile mit zu liefern ich meine warum sollte man ein netzteil mit liefern bei einem handy
bei einem smartphone was 1600 euro kostet kann man sich schon mal sparen ja ich sehe also ultra
nachholbettest du das samsung interessant ehrlich gesagt ich warte mal bis ich den preis höre aber
wahrscheinlich nicht für samsung ebenso beim wireless charging 15 watt sind nichts besonderes mehr vor
allem in dieser preisklasse fazit immer dann wenn sich beim design nichts tut dann sind wir versucht
zu denken dass sich auch sonst nicht viel getan hat aber das wäre dieses ja einfach falsch anzunehmen
denn der prozess allein der verändert so viel endlich haben wir eine flüssige performance und
eine super gute akkulaufzeit so wie das letztes jahr hätte auch schon sein sollen aber halt einfach
leider nicht wahr und dann gibt es noch alleinstellungsmerkmale wie zum beispiel den
s-pen oder die schärfste kamera und die langen software updates ja man könnte fast meinen 1400
euro wären angemessen aber dann denke ich daran dass ein google pixel 7 pro ist schon eine hausnummer
halt 800 euro kostet und das nutze ich sogar ein ganz klein bisschen lieber auch wenn mir der s-pen
und der ultra schall fingerabdrucksensor hier draus fehlen werden ich bin ja baustellen sind
für samsung weiterhin vor allem bei dem preis der fingerabdrucksensor weil der könnte halt noch
größer und noch besser sein und fast charging man kann sich eine grafikkarte kaufen von diesem
video ich hoffe es war für euch hilfreich macht es gut bis zum nächsten mal also ich ich werde
mal mein iphone bleiben und zwar auch jetzt wieder wenn ich mir ein neues gerät kaufe also ich
brauche ja ich brauche ein neues handy beziehungsweise ein neues smartphone ich habe ja aktuell seit einer
weile das was ich von der firma zur verfügung gestellt bekomme benutze ich auch als privates
gerät aber nachdem ich dort bald weg bin muss ich das natürlich zurückgeben
ne das ist ein iphone 11 glaube ich was ich habe von der firma glaube ich glaube ich ein iphone 11
bekommste kein neues bei der neuen firma doch ich bekomme neues bei der oh es hält mich nicht so
ich bekomme neues bei der neuen firma und ich bekomme ich darf das sogar privat benutzen aber
ich nehme die alte telefonnummer mit und dann müsste ich mal zumindest übergangsweise
auf aufs handy verzichten für für zwei wochen oder so das habe ich jetzt habe ich nicht vor
dann hätte ich mir kein neues gekauft das iphone 11 ist vollkommen in ordnung also
jetzt noch kein neues gekauft und die mache ich vielleicht auch ja ich das heißt ich werde auf
jeden fall zu einem anbieter gehen wo es die möglichkeit gibt das ganze per e sim zu machen
und dann mache ich das vielleicht auch rein in mein neues firmen handy dann aber mal gucken
am besten ist ja wenn es dual sim möglichkeiten gibt weil dann kann ich immer ein eigenes handy
rein machen und in das firmen handy was ich privat benutzen darf mal gucken die neuen iphone haben
kein fingerabdrucksensor ich glaube nicht die haben nur face wie heißt das face face id ohne
scheiß lehrer ist was was ich im leben nicht machen würde wie renovieren ein altbau
wartholm stels ok also was gucken wir was haben wir die harte realität als software entwickler
ein tag als software entwickler ok das gucken wir uns jetzt an ein tag als software entwickler
im büro und lasst mich raten er wird wahrscheinlich was arbeiten und nicht nur den ganzen tag
tischkicker spielen oder in der kantine hocken wie das in den promo videos immer drinne ist
ne das geht bei uns nicht also wir bekommen das handy also die haben die handys bei uns
auch nur geleast soweit ich weiß also die haben irgendwie so eine liese und leasing vertrag und
deswegen werden die handys auch alle zwei drei jahre ausgetauscht
alle drei jahre doch alle zwei drei jahre ausgetauscht sebaro bist ja auch mal wieder
da progas und deswegen kannst du dir auch nicht übernehmen aber es mir auch ist mir
auch egal ich bin ja der ebald weg insofern ok also guck mal einen tag als software entwickler
büro lange zeit endlich mal wieder ein vlog ein vlog gleich mal 8k gleich mal ein 8k du musst dir
mal das sony reveal video vom xperia eins was was ist das sechs ne vier oder eins zuvor
anschauen das ist mal ein richtig nices teil ja kann ich machen schick mal
erst mal schön zeit erfassung einchecken
ok der ist früh unterwegs früher bin ich 5 45 aufgestanden mittlerweile dank
dank home office muss ich oftmals tatsächlich 37 aufstehen bin dann direkt quasi bei der
arbeit wenn ich auf die arbeit verstehe ich meistens auch 37 auf so dass ich dann so ungefähr kurz
vor neun auf der arbeit bin ja früher 5 45 leute was meint ihr denn warum ich so dran gewöhnt bin
um 22 uhr ins bettke zu gehen was meint ihr warum ich warum ich bettke teil mache immer um 22 uhr
das kommt noch daher weil ich früher 5 45 aufgestanden bin und 5 45 sage ich euch selbst 22
uhr bettke war da teilweise ziemlich ziemlich knapp das mache ich aber schon immer so
schon fast immer ok gucken wir mal diesmal von meinem büro aus als ich seriously ich würde den
arbeitsplatz die position nicht mögen wobei der das geht noch ich mag position nicht im büro wo
laufend hinter die leute vorbeilaufen können dann sehen die ja dass ich den ganzen tag nichts
mache und youtube videos gucken aber ich mag das nicht wenn leute bei mir auf den bildschirm gucken
oder gucken können deswegen würde ich wahrscheinlich eher den platz dahinten bevorzugen oder was mit
einer wand dazwischen diesmal von meinem büro aus als normalerweise nicht so oft ins büro die
meiste zeit arbeite von meiner coding cave aus aber heute haben wir ein bisschen workshop und wo
den cave aber die von meiner coding cave aus der meint von von seinem arbeitsplatz von seinem
schreibtisch daheim oder aber heute haben wir ein bisschen workshop ich frage mich was die
coding cave sein soll ein paar meetings mit meinem arbeitskollegen aus dem ios team und
da werde ich euch natürlich mitnehmen werde ich ein bisschen erklären was wir so machen und ich
glaube es wird ein ganz cooler tag also für die leute die ich check ehrlich gesagt ich check die
iphone und ios entwickler nicht die arbeiten den ganzen tag immer mit ihrem trackpad und
ihrer notebook tastatur ich halte ich würde das überhaupt nicht aushalten ich brauche eine
ordentliche tastatur und ich brauche eine ordentliche maus ich kann sonst gar nicht arbeiten aber ich
habe das total oft gesehen die ganzen die ganzen ios leute oder oder mac os die stehen komplett auf
nur ihr notebook zu verwenden ich könnte das net ich würde ich würde zu echt zustände kriegen
die nicht wissen wo ich arbeite ich bin software entwickler bei wipo tv und arbeite an der iphone
ipad und tv os ab mit wifu tv habe ich das habe ich das richtig verstanden
zuallererst arbeite ich an tracking transparency das ist dieser system dialog den du wenn du ein
iphone nutzer bist garantiert schon mal in verschiedenen apps gesehen hast ja bevor wir
diesen dialog anzeigen blenden wir allerdings unseren eigenen screen ein damit wir die nutzer
über diesen dialog informieren können okay das natürlich sinnvoll es ist immer dass das kann ich
das kann ich verstehen es ist immer ein bisschen merkwürdig wenn der app aufgeht und du sofort
du sofort den den den dialog bekommst diese app möchte da entstanden oder denkst du immer
also ich habe die app noch nicht mal aufgemacht was wollen die überhaupt mit meinem standort
also da ist es tatsächlich besser wenn man bescheid sagt ich meine das ist natürlich jetzt
auch relativ nicht sagen wollen sie uns dabei helfen das fernseherlebnis noch weiter wie
zu sagen nein es gibt es jetzt allerdings noch nicht das heißt ich muss den jetzt erst mal
programmieren dazu habe ich so eine design vorlage von unserer designerin bekommen und
genau ich versuche dir jetzt einfach eins zu eins so im code nachzubilden
wie er arbeitet auch wirklich ich dachte eigentlich wenn ich mir die
ganzen werbe videos immer angucke die sitzen den ganzen tag nur rum mit spielen tischkicker
sitzen in der kantine mieten oder machen irgendwelche fitnessübungen dass der arbeitet ja wirklich
das ist übrigens mein arbeitskollege reiner und wir beide sind praktisch das komplette ios
team einmal am tag um 10 uhr 30 haben wir dann unser daily meeting da besprechen wir dann mit
unserer produkt managerin an welchen aufgaben wir am vortag gearbeitet haben was für heute ansteht
was so die pläne sind in der ganzen woche und so weiter alles was so anfällt damit wir einfach
ein alignment haben also jeder weiß was zu tun ist damit nicht bestimmte aufgaben auf der strecke
liegen bleiben oder an manchen aufgaben einfach doppelt gearbeitet wird und genau das ist einfach
so ein ganz normales team meeting wo wir einfach alles besprechen was uns gerade also mit drei
leuten geht das ja wenigstens dann artet das auch nicht aus weil bei größeren dailies artet das
oftmals zu so einer so einer prestige runde aus so eigentlich soll jeder mal kurz was erzählen
dann labern an manche leute fünf minuten rum weil sie halt denken sie müssen jetzt groß raus
prosauen was für geile sachen sie machen dass es gut ankommt und gerade wenn es ein meeting ist
wo dann auch noch derjenige dabei ist der vielleicht über gehalserhöhung oder sonst was in zukunft
entscheidet hast du leute die tragen da immer extrem dick auf die labern und labern und hören
überhaupt nicht auf und schwätzen da einen halben tag und brauchen dann quasi die gar fast die halbe
zeit von dem gesamten meeting alleine schon bei acht personen so in den sinn kommt
ich muss ja sagen die kleser sehen schon sehr hipster stylish aus franz muss man aufs klo
erst mal richtig reinhauen soll was das sein
die zweite aufgabe für heute ist ein meeting mit reiner bei dem wir mal gemeinsam die komplette
app also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das echt spaß macht wenn die zwei sich verstehen also so
ein zweier team da steht und fällt halt mit der mit der chemie zwischen zwischen den leuten
wenn die sich gut verstehen dann funktioniert das wunderbar wenn die sich nicht abkönnen so
wo es nicht aussieht dann macht es absolut keinen poch dann fangst du dich den ganzen tag nur ab
detektur also alle komponenten die unsere app hat auf ein whiteboard zu malen und zu schauen ob
wir dinge vielleicht zusammenführen können vielleicht manche module aufteilen einfach das
kann man sich vorstellen wie sie eine größere aufräumen aktionen unsere apps sind an sich
ziemlich komplex denn wenn man mal überlegt wir haben eine ios app dann haben wir eine für tv
os also für den apple tv und für jede von diesen plattformen haben wir unsere eigene wiper tv app
und dazu noch die o2 tv also im prinzip ist es die gleiche app nur in einem anderen branding jetzt
die gleiche app nur dass auch tu da ihr logo reingeklatscht hat aus aus gründen so eine
visualisierung unserer code base hilft natürlich um mal zu verstehen wie die ganzen komponenten
miteinander interagieren und welche zusammenhänge es gibt alles was wir jetzt auf dieses whiteboard
geschrieben haben können wir dann im anschluss erstmal fotografieren und dann in ein richtiges
digitales board übertragen wie beispielsweise miro es gibt ja so cooles habs und sowas wo man
das auch schon digital machen kann wobei ich muss ehrlich sagen dort wo ich aktuell arbeite haben
wir auf jeder auf jedem stockwerk zwei solche habs räume und ich habe die dinger glaube ich
noch nie ernsthaft benutzt also ich habe die am anfang ein paar mal benutzt weil ich es cool
fand so großen bildschirm zu haben wo man drauf malen kann und sowas danach habe ich die räume
nie wieder gebucht nie wieder gebucht damit wir das einfach für unsere interne dokumentation haben
so das meeting ist jetzt vorbei und ich mache mich jetzt auch schon 16 uhr 16 uhr da könnte man
eigentlich so langsam nach heim gehen oder direkt an die arbeit für meine dritte und letzte aufgabe
des tages und zwar gibt es in unserer app eine live seeking funktion das bedeutet eigentlich nur
dass wenn du live tv die dage schrift für den sub oder irgendetwas anderes dann kannst du zum
einen natürlich pause und weiter drücken obwohl es live tv ist und du kannst während einer
sendung innerhalb des streams spulen das heißt wenn du beispielsweise ein fußballspiel anschaust
und ein tor verpasst hast dann musst du dir nicht unbedingt die wiederholung anschauen sondern
kann es ganz flexibel eine oder zwei oder vielleicht noch zehn minuten einfach in die
vergangenheit zurückspulen und von dort aus weiterschauen diese funktion hatten wir in der
vergangenheit schon für unsere iphone ipad app integriert jetzt hat rein das ganze noch für
unsere tv os ab gebaut da diese codeänderungen jetzt nicht einfach so ohne dass irgendjemand
rüber geschaut hat in unsere app reingehen ist es jetzt meine aufgabe den kompletten code aller
änderungen von dieser speziellen funktion jetzt erst mal einer erzählen was er dafür
missprogrammiert hat wobei die zwei scheinen sich ja gut zu verstehen ich denke da ist das
da ist das weniger ein problem aber das wäre jetzt so der punkt wenn du ein zweier team hast und
die zwei leute sich nicht abkönnen dann würde jetzt wahrscheinlich rum genervt werden an jeder
kleinsten kleinigkeit testen und schauen ob es da vielleicht irgendwelche probleme gibt dieses
ganze prozedere nennt man code review weil ich eben den code von einer anderen personen review
also mache ich genau das ich schaue mir den ganzen code jetzt an installiere die app auf
meinem lokalen gerät und dann schaue ich ob alles funktioniert so wie es sein sollte und wenn alles
passt dann gibt es meine prove also mein daumen nach oben sozusagen und falls irgendetwas noch
nicht funktioniert oder irgendetwas vielleicht noch um geändert werden sollte dann schreibe ich
ganz einfach meine kommentare reiner kann diese ganzen kommentare durchgehen dann seine code
änderungen wieder machen und dann wenn alles in ordnung ist dann können wir diese funktion an
alle leute rausbringen offensichtlich sieht nicht jeder tag gleich aus also an manchen tagen gibt
es mehr gesagt wie viel berufs erfahrung hat meh aber da hat in einem der letzten videos mal
erzählt also er macht das wohl auch schon eine ganze weile dann einem der letzten videos erzählt
dass so ein bisschen seine stationen was wir was wir mal vor vor nicht so langer zeit geguckt haben
hat er ihm ein bisschen seine stationen erzählen das war irgendwie so drei vier verschiedene sachen
also er macht das wohl auch schon ist auch schon eine ganze weile wie lange weiß ich natürlich
vielleicht sagt das ja in dem video was gerade so ansteht jetzt haben wir auch schon 18 uhr
18 uhr werden wir viel zu spät also 18 uhr ist mir einfach zu spät also wenn ich ins büro fahre an
den büro tagen mache ich ja auch minus stunden zum größten teil da bin ich meistens von so kurz
vor 9 bis so 15 uhr 15 auf der arbeit und dann fahre ich wieder heim dann mache ich so eineinhalb
stunden minus oder sowas aber trotzdem macht nichts jetzt wird franz erstmal eingepackt das
heißt ich mache jetzt feierabend der tag ist natürlich noch nicht vorbei denn ich treffe
mich mit einem sehr guten freund zum abendessen das wäre schon viel so sozial für mich ich
würde heimfahren und stream anmachen oder mmo kreisel grind ich hoffe dieser kleine ein blick
in meinen bin ich froh dass wir den erst beim essen gesehen haben ich hätte ich gefallen also
falls ihr mehr solche blogs aus meinem was ich gut finde ist man hat tatsächlich mal gesehen er
arbeitet ja tatsächlich also nicht so wie diese ganzen image image filme day live nebi was was
one day in the life of a software developer oder sowas sondern einfach mal ein ganz normaler
arbeitstag wo man sieht ok der macht eigentlich auch wirklich den ganzen tag irgendwas natürlich
kannst du nicht den ganzen tag immer hoch konzentriert nur am programmieren sein das
klappt natürlich auch gehirnmäßig nicht aber macht halt einfach den ganzen tag was das ist
viel realistischer als diese ganzen werbe videos pro alltag sehen wollt oder auch von zu hause aus
dem homeoffice dann lasst es mich in den kommentaren wissen gibt im video einen daumen
nach oben wenn es euch gefallen hat abonnieren nicht vergessen um keine weiteren videos mehr
zu verpassen ich hoffe wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal ok das mit dem essen gehen weiter lifestyle
part jetzt dein kevin hey immer mal den kommen jetzt kann ich das videos nämlich zu lang 30
minuten wie kommst du dann aus den minus stunden wieder raus ganz einfach wenn ich homeoffice habe
kann ich ja schon 37 anfangen und bin dann auch sieben oder sieben oder meistens sogar schon
sieben sieben auf 15 fang ich so sieben Uhr 10 sagen wir mal sieben Uhr 10 an und dann mache
ich halt bis sagen wir mal 16 Uhr 16 Uhr 30 das ist dann ungefähr die zeit wo ich normalerweise
auch wenn ich in frankfurt heimkomme heimkommen würde und da kann ich quasi die zeit die ich
sonst pendel obendrauf hauen und dann habe ich wieder plus das gleicht sich ganz gut aus
ein weiterer kund warum homeoffice extrem gut ist
was haben wir denn sonst noch hier zu bieten
wir renovieren einen altbau die harte realität noch kommen jetzt haben wir
gerade schon was auf der entwicklungsstelle es kommen aber noch eine drauf wurde mir
letztens vorgeschlagen das video ich glaube ich glaube er hat glück er hat als kleiner channel
mal so ein bisschen in den algoritmus geschafft sonst wäre mir das nicht vorgeschlagen worden
aber guck mal was er zu meckern hat die harte realität als software entwickler ich bin tim
und während meiner reise er kommt aus hamburg oder wo kommt hier mehr als software entwickler sind
mir mehrere herausforderungen begegnet die mir anfangs gar nicht so bewusst waren ich will mit
dir heute über drei themen reden die normalerweise verschwiegen werden dabei noch ein paar hilfreiche
tips damit dein traum nicht zum albtraum wird den alltag als software entwickler habe ich mir
damals ungefähr sofort er guckt aber viel der guckt an viel zu durchdringend an im video
gegen mittags aufstehen aus dem bett den laptop greifen und ein paar zeilen code schreiben gut
vielleicht nicht ganz so habe ich mir das so habe ich mir das ehrlich gesagt nie vorgestellt
aber ich habe mir es auch nicht so vorgestellt wie sie den ganzen werbe videos immer gezeigt wird
so extrem aber es könnte nicht weiter von der realität entfernt meint ihr das ist ein video
ai dass er uns die ganze zeit anguckt
unflexible arbeitszeiten aber die sind auch häufig flexibel in die richtung früher anzufangen und
später aufzuhören mein alltag heute besteht eher daraus probleme zu lösen die noch keiner
gelöst hat und es noch keinen konkreten lösungsweg gibt trotzdem besteht die erwartung
perfekte zeitabschätzung zu treffen das stimmt ich glaube das kennt jeder software entwicklung
ist aber sagt man IT im allgemeinen so diese so diese frage so nach dem motto zum beispiel wenn
was kaputt ist ja so nach dem motto ausfall ausfall ausfall hilfe ist was kaputt und dann
sagt ja moment ich gucke mal was meinst du denn wie lang es dauern wird ebenso keine ahnung du hast
mir gerade gesagt dass was kaputt ist ich habe mich noch nicht mal eingeloggt ja sagt aber so
ungefähr kann so prima daum kann so ungefähr abschätzen keine ahnung man ich wusste bis eben
noch bis vor zehn sekunden nicht mal das was kaputt ist ja aber du musst auch ungefähr wissen
was es sein könnte und diese auch einzuhalten außerdem wurden die probleme gerne von oben
nach oben ist es ein wieder ei er guckt ein wirklich sehr durchdringend an und und pinsel
auch nicht dabei wird und wer muss das dann alles zum schluss irgendwie lösen na klar ich
als software entwickler aber es ist dann häufig vorgekommen dass sich die probleme auch mit in
den feierabend genommen habe das stimmt einschlafen nicht richtig das stimmt wenn man gar so sehr
tagsüber das ist tatsächlich auch ein nachteil deswegen ist so wie es so wie es in dem letzten
video gezeigt wurde wahrscheinlich der viel bessere ansatz dass man schon ordentlich was
schafft am tag aber dass man halt nicht wirklich so diese diese diesen hardcore crime machen muss
so nach dem motto das muss jetzt so in drei stunden fertig oder muss jetzt in drei tagen
fertig sein und die leute sitzen wirklich zehn stunden am tag davor und versuchen daran irgendwas
zu entwickeln erst kommt da nichts gescheites bei raus es läuft dann vielleicht irgendwie am
ende aber es kommt nichts gescheites bei raus und dein kopf ist wirklich komplett voll mit dem
scheiß also du träumst dann auch davon und sowas irgendwie schwören immer die gedanken im kopf
herum wie ich das problem denn jetzt lösen könnte kann ich mir vorstellen auch immer wieder erleben
dürfen besonders in stressigen zeiten wird dann mit druck reagiert und die crunch time eingeleitet
aber ist tage die länger als zehn stunden dauern waren dann auch keine selten ich muss ich muss ich
muss es jetzt einfach einfach auslassen die crunch time eingeleitet aber ist tage die länger als
zehn stunden dauern waren dann einfach zu gut zum video gepasst keine seltenheiten denn das
feature muss ja schließlich fertig werden private angelegenheiten hast du gefälligst nach hinten
anzustellen damit will ich sehr gut also ganz ehrlich das mag vielleicht der ein oder andere
arbeitgeber so sehen aber da hat er pech also wenn es so nach dem motto du hast gefälligst
deine privaten angelegenheiten hinten anzustellen das mag dass das kann man vielleicht argumentieren
ja so wenn ich meine normale arbeit in der zeit wo ich meine tägliche arbeitszeit erfülle vielleicht
ja je nachdem wie wichtig diese angelegenheiten sind also wenn mich jetzt keine ahnung irgendwie meine
mutter anrufen würde sie hat ein autounfall ist mir das vollkommen egal ob ich jetzt irgendwas
fertig basteln soll oder nicht würde ich jetzt würde ich hinfahren aber ansonsten haben die
schlicht und ergreifend gelitten und meiner erfahrung nach ist auch so umso ausgeglichener
dass ganze gehandhabt wird umso eher sind die leute auch mal bereit freiwillig über das
verpflichtende hinaus was zu machen also wenn zum beispiel der arbeitgeber auch mal entgegenkommt
mit du kannst kurzfristig mal weg oder kannst hier das und das mal machen dann bist du vielleicht
auch deutlich eher bereit kurzfristig am wochenende mal einzuspringen wenn wartungsarbeiten sind obwohl
dir vorher keiner bescheid gesagt hat und sowas wenn das immer so auf so so so auf auf wie nennt
man das so ganz knapp auf ganz passend genäht ist alles dann wird es irgendwann dazu führen dass
die leute sachen nein dass die leute sagen sie erfüllen sie erfüllen exakt das was definiert
ist und da ist zum beispiel definiert drei tage vor wartungsarbeiten bescheid sagen wie du hast
nicht drei tage vor wartungsarbeiten bescheid gesagt dann mache ich es nicht ich habe eine stunde
reaktionszeit am handy dann bin ich auch erst nach 59 minuten am rechner das wird dann letztendlich
auf so eine auslegung rauslaufen wenn man sich gegenseitig zu sehr abfuckt und deswegen ist es
besser man man kommt sich gegenseitig ein bisschen entgegen eine sache die man aktuellen arbeitgeber
auch ein bisschen sich verschoben hat die letzten jahre über auch einer der punkte warum ich da
kein bock mehr drauf hab und dann sind die leute auch bereit zu sagen hey gut ja ich weiß es ist
freitag eigentlich hättet ihr mir vorher bescheid sagen müssen aber ich habe samstag eh nix
großartiges vor ja wenn der nicht kann erzählen mal was anlegt sunde work life balance als
software entwickler zu finden das ist gar nicht so einfach sein das ist nicht einfach je nach je
nach arbeitgeber definitiv aber es ist ein wichtiger punkt und ich habe den eindruck dass und da können
die ganzen boomer meiner an sich nach tatsächlich von den jungen leuten was lernen und zwar ich
glaube die jüngere und aktuell anfangende und gerade in job gestartet vor ein paar jahren
generation hat das besser verstanden als die alten ich glaube so ab meiner generation und jünger bei
meiner generation fing so ein bisschen an dass die leute da deutlich mehr drauf geguckt haben aber
die meisten in meiner generation sind noch so wir machen jetzt den karriere kreisel kreint und das
ist das wichtigste im leben aber ab der generation danach wurde es wurde das schon anders und heute
habe ich eindruck viele leute die heute mit dem job anfangen die machen das eben nicht mehr mit
dem hintergrund ich will jetzt den quasi karriere machen ist das ist ist mein höchstes ziel im
leben sondern die gehen tatsächlich zum größten teil mit der einstellung ran hey karriere machen
bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo man ordentlich kohle verdient und gut über die runden kommt und dann
scheiß drauf was auch was meiner meinung nach die beste einstellung ist weil wenn du mal irgendwann
keine ahnung 90 bist und diese überlegt ha was hätte ich in meinem leben anders machen sollen
die wenigsten werden sagen ja ich hätte mal unbedingt mehr arbeiten müssen und besonders als
einsteiger finde ich es extrem schwierig mir persönlich ging es am anfang so dass ich mich
beweisen wollte und ein bisschen mehr gegeben habe und dieses muster ja wenn man neu ist ist
das ja auch nicht verkehrt da muss man erst mal ein bisschen eindruck machen vielleicht an manchen
stellen oder es ist nicht ja nicht nicht verwerflich einsteigern wieder mir das letztendlich geholfen
eine 32 stundenwoche beste beste beste 32 stundenwoche das habe ich das video habe ich
schon gesehen das kommt mir bekannt vor sekunde habe ich sogar kommentar drunter geschrieben
jetzt mit 32 stundenwoche jetzt fällt mir das ein das video habe ich doch schon geguckt
da bin ich doch
32 stundenwoche ist mir wieder eingefallen dass ich dazu was gesagt habe
gestern nee das war war das ja das war nee das war vorgestern vorgestern habe ich da was
drunter geschrieben one day stimmt nicht das blödsinn ich habe vielleicht edited one day
ich habe das am freitag gesehen als ich mein mein video hochgeladen hat weil das war in den
empfehlungen unter meinem eigenen video aber auch nicht für jeden möglich ist aber leute vier
tage woche ist mit abstand das beste was er besser besser gesagt muss ja man kann es sich
ja einteilen wie man will aber teilzeit arbeiten ist das beste was ihr machen könnt also wenn
ihr mit eurem geld über die runden kommt und auch mit ein bisschen weniger über die runden
kommen würdet diese 20 prozent sind einfach ein riesenunterschied es ist viel mehr als 20 prozent
das geld macht nicht so viel aus finde ich und die die die mehr zeit die man hat ist viel mehr als
es so offen papier aussieht weil normalerweise weil normalerweise ist es so ich werde ich werde
das jetzt mal ich werde das mal versuchen zu beschreiben wie das normalerweise abläuft also
montags bis freitag arbeiten freitag mittag fertig und das aber freitag nachmittag fertig so
wirklich großartig bock irgendwie da groß was zu machen freitags hat man eh nicht gerade wenn
man ins bureau muss und erst irgendwie 18 uhr mit hin und her fahren oder sonst wieder heim ist
hat man kein bock mehr was zu machen also freitag ist eigentlich gelaufen samstag ist der erste
tag wo du was machen könntest aber du musst erst mal pennen weil du die ganze woche über
nicht richtig gepennt hast also nicht komplett ausgeschlafen warst weil du musst ja irgendwie
hin und her pendeln und machen und gedönst und deswegen kannst du samstag ausschlafen hast du
penst erst mal ein bisschen länger am samstag dass du mal das samstag so der erste tag der
woche ist wo du mal wieder richtig wach bist und samstag geht die woche dann los nicht montags
dann machst du samstags die sachen die du die woche über nicht machen konntest von einkaufen
gehen bis aufräumen bis irgendwas umräumen bis zeugs machen dinger machen ja tagsüber musste
die ein oder anderen sachen muss man was erledigt sind samstags dann gibt es leute die der meinung
sind ok samstag abend musste dich hart besaufen feiern gehen was auch immer machen ok weil
ring samstag samstag nachmittag abend können wir wohl so zusammenfassen da macht jeder worauf
er bock hat dann schläft er sonntags aus und ab sonntag mittag denkst du dir eigentlich schon
fack das wochenende ist ja schon wieder vorbei weil morgen muss ich wieder früh aufstehen und
dann ist die sache auch gelaufen so so sieht normales wochenende aus also eigentlich mega für
den arsch und wenn du montags noch frei hast wenn du noch einen tag mehr frei hast dann ist es
überhaupt gar kein ding also mal prinzipiell bist du eh ein bisschen wacher die woche über gerade
wenn du homeoffice machen kannst weil du im tag mehr mehr zeit hast dich dich auszuruhen das heißt
du musst samstag jetzt auch nicht irgendwie einen halben tag pennen du hast vielleicht freitags
noch ein bisschen energie was was zu machen du hast den ganzen samstagzeit du hast den ganzen
sonntagzeit und am sonntag machst du dir auch keine gedanken müsste ich muss früh aufstehen
montag schläft auch ganz normal machst an montag noch den tag was du machen willst und montag abend
denkst du dir so ja gut jetzt war eigentlich relativ lange wochenende jetzt habe ich keine
schmerzen mit auf die arbeit zu gehen also das ist einfach viel viel besser obwohl man nur 20
prozent quasi weniger arbeitet und 20 prozent weniger geld kriegt ist musst du lernen ab und
zu mal nein zu sagen oder auch mal bei feierabend den stift fallen zu lassen hinterfragt dabei die
features auch kritisch und macht ihr bewusst ob das wirklich gerade notwendig ist denn eine
schlechte planung auf der anderen seite ist kein notfall auf deiner seite das ist richtig da hat
er recht das ist das ist das ist gut das kann man sich merken eine schlechte planung auf der
anderen seite ist kein notfall auf deiner seite richtig so sieht es aus es wird oftmals einfach
komplett verkackt was koordination und planung angeht und da denken sie so nach dem motto ja
es reicht doch wenn wir am freitag fragen ob der typ samstag 23 uhr was machen kann wenn in der
vergangenheit alles sagen wir mal zu beidseitiger zufriedenheit gehändelt wurde dann ist die
chance dass derjenige sagt ja mache ich relativ hoch aber wenn das nicht so ist dann sagen die
leute halt leck mich gibt es nicht und damit müssen sie dann auch rechnen ja also das stimmt
schon nur weil die planung verkackt ich meine man muss es man muss es hat schon recht man muss
es halt dynamisch handhaben wenn ansonsten alles gut läuft finde ich kann man ohne probleme sagen
ja dann spring ich mal samstag ein kurzfristig wenn es halt nicht so ist dann dann halt auch pech
ich schaffe es jetzt zumindest mal rechtzeitig feierabend zu machen doch das beste ist wenn
man ich kenne das also mir fällt es auch immer immer schwer bei bei speziellen thematiken zu
sagen so nö das mache ich jetzt nicht jetzt gehe ich heim oder sowas in der richtung aber ganz im
ernst da kann man die oma taktik machen wie wir aus dem aller allerersten video heute gesehen
haben man sagt einfach aber das ist jetzt aber schlecht ich habe schon was vor und und wenn
du es ganz konkret machen willst denkst du dir halt irgendwas aus ich habe einen termin
beim keine ahnung beim rathaus ich muss mein personalausweis verlängern lassen oder irgendwie
sowas in der richtung man und dann sagen die leute immer haben da kann man nichts machen
zum stillstand bleibt keine dank agiler arbeitsmethoden mehr produktivität aus
mir raus zu holen und das daily was mir ja wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich weil die auf
dem papier moment das bleibt keine dank agiler arbeitsmethoden wird versucht immer mehr
produktivität aus mir raus zu holen ja das ist das passiert bei unternehmen die sagen sie sind
agil und arbeiten nach agilen methoden und methodik und allen möglichen sachen sind es
aber eigentlich gar nicht die machen quasi das was sie vorher gemacht haben mit mit dem
gleichen shit aus projekt manager der dann auf dem daily scrum rumsteht der da übrigens gar
nix zu suchen hat und und solche geschichten und sagen sie sind agil bei einem kollegen wurde mal
rumgemerkt weil er auf dir mit ganz ehrlich die sind teilweise so los die müssen sich nicht
wundern wenn ihnen die leute wegrennen man kann perso verlängern nee du kannst nicht verlängern
du kannst neuen beantragen was ich jetzt auch machen muss weil mein ausweis ist abgelaufen
und ich hatte der zwischenzeitlich schon so ein vorübergehenden personalausweis weil ich
postident machen wollte und der ist auch abgelaufen wieder das heißt ich muss jetzt nächste woche da
mal hin mein ausweis verlängern beziehungsweise mein ausweis mein ausweis erneuern lassen weil
ich muss ein polizeiliches führungszeugnis beantragen für meinen neuen job und das
kriegt man glaube ich nur mit einem gültigen ausweis würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
und das daily was mich eigentlich unterstützen soll das wird zum status meeting ja das kenne ich
ja nicht zu langsam arbeiten das kenne ich das war das passiert auch bei vielen unternehmen die
der meinung sind wir sind agil aber nicht agil sodass dann wisst ihr der chef sitzt drin der
project manager ist jetzt drinne im daily dann geht das daily nicht so sehr zum täglichen austausch
wofür es eigentlich gedacht ist wo es auch mal ok ist zu sagen ich habe eigentlich nichts spannendes
zu erzählen sondern zu ich bin der geilste und denkt mal bei der nächsten gehalserhöhung an mich
das ist tatsächlich so eine so eine falle wo glaube ich viele unternehmen reintappen ja
ja das wird zum status meeting zweck entfremdet damit wir ja nicht zu langsam arbeiten auf
verständnis für probleme zu treffen bei nicht er hört sich ein bisschen unglücklich in seinem
aktuellen job an leuten ist auch quasi unmöglich außerdem merke ich wie das backlog immer weiter
und weiter wächst es sollen immer mehr features existieren und habe ich ein ticket abgearbeitet
existieren schon drei neue es fühlt sich irgendwie wie ein kamp an den ich gar nicht gewinnen kann
vielleicht leute ernsthaft ich kann es jetzt erzählen weil es egal ich bin eh bald weg das
ist eines der gründe warum ich schon überhaupt nicht mehr ins ticket system reingucke ich habe
teilweise tickets die habe ich zwei wochen nicht gesehen das einzige was ich mache ist wenn wir
wenn wir unser unsere weekly besprechung haben dann stelle ich die neuen tickets auf in prüfung
weil dann tauchen sie nicht in der unzugewiesenen liste auf und sobald tickets nicht mehr in der
unzugewiesenen in der unzugewiesenen liste auftauchen fallen sie keine mehr auf selbst wenn
du sie einfach zwei jahre liegen lässt klar letztendlich die probleme gehen davon ich weg
und manche und manche sachen manche sachen sind mir da auch schon ein bisschen auf die
füße gefallen so nach dem motto zum beispiel habe ich total verpasst das darfst eigentlich auch
keinem erzählen wir haben eigentlich einmal im im quartal alle drei monate haben wir eine
root pass ein root password change für alle linux systeme so und das hat sich irgendwie so
eingebürgert dass ich dafür zuständig bin den root password change auf allen systemen zu
machen root password change root password change ist easy easy as fuck ja du generierst neues
password packst das packst das in safe und den hashtrick so ins config management einlässt
es auf allen linux server auswahl an sich ist an sich das ist total easy aber ich habe ein ticket
bekommen root pass ich sage jetzt mal irgendwas ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher wanns gewesen
ich sage root password change drittes quartal 2022 habe ich ein ticket bekommen und ich habe
halt nicht in das ticket system reingekuckt und irgendwann ist mir keine ahnung zwei monate
später oder so aufgefallen wir hätten ja root password change machen muss also was haben wir
gemacht wir haben dann einfach den quartal vier root password change gemacht und alles war wieder
gut und es sich ja den job zu wechseln denke ich mir und da wird mir erst bewusst wie schnell sich
die softwareentwicklung immer weiterentwickelt das was am anfang des jobs noch als modern galt
ist mittlerweile schon etwas veraltet dauerhaft ja zum beispiel das was was fällt mir ein was war
ok nagios nagios zum beispiel interessiert heute kein mensch mehr nagios war als ich noch die
ausbildung gemacht habe war das ganz furchtbar geil alter nagios war poggers natürlich könnte
man jetzt auch irgendwelche frameworks nehmen so von jquery im frontend und so solche geschichten
aber ich überlege gerade mal so im im defops admin bereich was war damals voll der angesagte
shit den jetzt keiner mehr interessiert also nagios fällt mir da sofort ein das war damals
total angesagt als monitoring lösung auf dem desktop hatte jeder der cool sein wollte linux
mit mit compets und drehen im würfel und sowas was hat auch keiner mehr verwendet was war damals
technologiemäßig angesagt gut die die selber und so sind neuer geworden und alles müsste ich
jetzt mal drüber nachdenken fällt mir spontan gar nicht so ja stimmt die gitt gitt hat damals
niemand verwendet das war noch svn oder oder cvs oder oder wie ist das andere mehr kuriel
oder sowas da auch noch gab ne java applets waren damals auch schon nicht mehr angesagt nicht mal
angesagt im browser wenn ich drüber nachdenken gefallen mir da bestimmt noch jede menge jede
menge sachen ein flash flash war auch nicht mehr so angesagt also immer noch immer noch weil ich
kann mich noch dran erinnern als das erste iphone rausgekommen ist und ab da ging es ja dann spätestens
richtig down hill was flash angeht aber so richtig krass angesagt würde ich gar nicht mal sagen aber
ich war ja auch nie im design bereich was sowas schittricks ja gut das gibt es ja heute immer noch
richtung basic ja ja ja ja vielleicht näher über ich überlege grad so im so im klassischen
admin bereich was war da angesagt haben wir dann open vpn war zum beispiel angesagt damals open
vpn heute ist es ja heute ist es ja ein bisschen weniger geworden obwohl immer noch vieles open
vpn ist ja mir fällt jetzt webs für lotus notes war damals angesagt leute genau lotus notes domino
und sowas und und war das web vier da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher ja das könnte web vier
gewesen sein so für anwendungs backends könnte web vier gewesen sein aber lotus lotus notes war
damals sehr angesagt ja egal wir gucken jetzt erst mal das video fertig
das lernt steht also an oberster stelle als software entwickler das stimmt da hat er recht
das ist das wird das wird aber auch immer so sein ich glaube nicht dass du jemals davon
wegkommen wird es sei denn du bist cobalt entwickler dich mit neuen sachen zu beschäftigen deswegen
denke ich dass in diesem beruf es sowohl als entwickler als auch im defops admin bereich
und so dass es da einen relativ hohen anteil an leute gibt die darin arbeiten die sich irgendwie
so dazu berufen fühlen kann ich jetzt schlecht schlecht beschreiben weil für mich ist es keine
wirkliche arbeit mich mit neuen sachen auseinanderzusetzen sofern es neue sachen sind die mich
interessieren mich interessiert jetzt auch nicht alles aber für mich ist es überhaupt keine arbeit
mich mit neuen sachen auseinanderzusetzen ich mache das eigentlich ganz gerne ich gucke mir
neue frameworks an ich gucke mir neue tools an neue technologien und versuche die dann so aufzubauen
und so zu verwenden dass sie irgendwie so in meiner vorstellung damit also ich versuche dann diese
tools so zu verwenden oder so zu lernen sie so zu verwenden dass ich so in meinem kopf für mich
denken kann ok das ist ein guter anwendungszweck für oder das ist ein guter weg das zu verwenden
und ich glaube deswegen gibt es auch ist da auch der anteil der leute die dort so so no life 24
sieben vom rechner hängen so hoch die sind die sind die sind irgendwie die sind irgendwie berufen
dazu ja die sind irgendwie so so also sie würden das auch machen ohne dass sie dafür geld bekommen
würden und ich meine damit jetzt nicht unbedingt vom rechner sitzen und fortnite spielen die
basics zu wiederholen ja das gut leute ich kann euch jetzt auch aus dem kopf nicht mehr genau alle
subnet den geschichten ausrechnen neue sicherheitsstandard ist oder das nächste halb thema was die nächste
firma einsetzen will irgendwie besteht die erwartungshaltung dass ich mein ganzes leben
den programmieren widme am besten habe ich noch mehrere nebenprojekte damit ich stetig besser
werde und immer was neues lerne das ganze führt zu meinem nächsten und zwar extrem viel stress
der meistens durch druck von oben oder selbst herbeigeführten druck entsteht in meinem umfeld
sehe ich dass auch immer wieder einige kollegen sind dadurch echt krank geworden und auch an mir
hat das nicht ganz halt gemacht um aber wirklich entspannen zu können solltest mein kanal abonnieren
als software entwickler also da ist überleitung ein leben lang neues zu lernen unrealistische
deadlines einzuhalten und immer mehr gut ganz ehrlich bei uns läuft es eher so die deadlines
mögen unrealistisch sein aber wenn es wirklich wichtig ist dass zu diesem an diesem tag auch
irgendwas erscheint dann erscheint an diesem tag auch irgendwas nur ist es dann oftmals nicht das
was ursprünglich gesagt wurde was dort erscheinen sollte das ist dann was was vielleicht so heißt
aber es wurden sich funktionen und und features und sachen raus definiert die dann erst im
nachhinein noch kommen also quasi so als dlc also die leute können ja auch nicht zaubern mehr
arbeit zu haben als du eigentlich schaffen kannst nicht umsonst ist die burnout rate bei software
entwicklern besonders hoch hierbei kann ich dir nur empfehlen einen arbeitgeber zu suchen der
weiterbildung fördert ihm die gesundheit seiner mitarbeiter wichtig ist und dass du auch zur
arbeit einen gesunden abstand hält von außen werde ich mittlerweile als experte wahrgenommen
oder zumindest als jemand ein bisschen auskennt mit dem thema aber hier stimmt irgendwie fremd und
eigenwahrnehmung nicht ganz überein ich selbst habe irgendwie immer das gefühl das ganze nicht
wirklich zu können und konzentriere mich dabei viel mehr auf die fehler die ich gemacht habe
anstatt auf meine erfolge irgendwie habe ich das gefühl die anderen können das viel besser als
ich und ich schummeln mich hier nur ein bisschen durch es ist nur eine frage der zeit bis ich nicht
mal weiterkomme und es an kritik hagelt meine herangehensweisen könnten auch deutlich besser
sein und die kollegen die bekommen das doch auch deutlich schneller und besser hin oder das ganze
ist als imposter syndrom bekannt die meisten haben höchstwahrscheinlich noch weniger plan dabei das
gefühl sein job nicht richtig zu machen irgendwie sich durchzuschummeln und dem ganzen nicht
gewachsen zu sein besonders unter software entwicklern ist das relativ weit verbreitet
und verdient auch sein eigenes video ich selbst habe damit auch immer mal wieder zu kämpfen gehabt
und auch glaube ich jeder also ich glaube das gefühl hat jeder schon mal so nach dem motto ich
habe eigentlich keine ahnung was ich hier mache jetzt wirklich der richtige fahrt für mich ist
ganz überwunden wobei ich manchmal wobei ich manchmal auch so ein bisschen so ein bisschen das
gegenteil ich habe wobei nicht wirklich das gegenteilig aber ein bisschen was anderes es
gibt halt themen damit setze ich mich schon so lange auseinander und die sind jetzt auch nicht
super komplex wenn man sie einfach benutzen will zum beispiel geht versionsverwaltung rein zum
benutzen ist das relativ easy also wenn man mal wenn man einen branche aufmachen muss was
entwickeln muss das pushen muss und das dann als pull request einreichen muss ist das eigentlich
relativ easy und ich kümmere mich halt um unsere um unsere repos um unsere quail code verwaltung
um unsere releases ich mache das ja schon jahrelang nicht jahrzehntelang aber jahrelang das heißt ich
benutze das täglich ich kenne mich da auch ganz gut aus klar sicherlich die manche manche ganz
aktuellen sachen habe ich auch nicht gehört die führen ja auch manchmal neue parametern oder
kenne ich auch nicht immer hundertprozentig alles aber wo ich manchmal das problem habe ist wenn
wir irgendwelche experten haben also ich rede ja wirklich für irgendwelche konsulten leute
diese eingekauft haben den ich dann erst mal erzählen muss ok hier liegt die sache bei uns in
github hier habe ich ungefähr beschrieben was in einem pull request wie so ein pull request
aussehen soll ja ich habe zum beispiel so ein pull request reingeschrieben wenn einer also in
so ein pull request guide habe ich schon mal vor jahren gemacht wenn jemand neue änderungen
eincheckt in unser config management wo dann die server eben letztendlich mit konfiguriert
werden was da drinne stehen soll ja da soll dann zum beispiel so sachen drinne stehen wie ticket
nummer des ursprünglichen auftrages betroffene systeme weil ich am ende nicht wirklich erkenne
auch wenn ich zwar verantwortlich für bin den kram aus auszuführen und das zu beauftragen also
kann ich ja nicht wissen was jede änderung im detail macht und welche systeme davon betroffen
sind das ist nichts großartiges kompliziertes was ich da reingeschrieben habe ja es soll das
ursprüngliche auftrags ticket drinstehen und es soll zum beispiel drinstehen welche systeme
dieser change betreffen soll planmäßig dass ich auch zum beispiel weiß wenn auf einmal auf
in einem anderen system was passiert ich für das ja in einer testumgebung vorher aus und da kommt
auf einmal auf den fileserver in oracle kleint da denke ich mir dann so der hatte eigentlich
nix zu suchen da hat sich eigentlich vertippt und das reicht eigentlich schon mehr muss da nicht
rein und ich drehe dann immer durch wenn es irgendwelche konsultants gibt oder leute die
das eigentlich wissen müssten wenn die nicht nur eins zweimal fragen sondern gefühlt bei
jedem pull request bei mir auf der matte stehen und fragen wie mache ich das denn jetzt mit
geht die tun immer so als ist das so eine komplette wissenschaft das ist easy erst fack wenn man sich
ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat es ist nicht so dass das super kompliziert wäre nicht umsonst
benutzt die ganze welt github als als frontend und geht als versionswahl das ist nicht schwierig in
der branche aufzumachen das zu implementieren zu push und pull das ist nicht schwierig es gibt
leute die stehen bei jedem pull request stehen die bei mir auf der matte und erzählen ja kannst du
mir das mit geht noch mal zeigen dass ich dann was mit geht dass der klingel wahrscheinlich auch schon
ein bisschen so was mit geht mein das kann ja alles bedeuten ja wie ich denn da dann so einen
rebase mache und so was das ist ja ok rebase ist jetzt vielleicht nicht was was man tagtäglich macht
aber wenn man das schon 20 mal gemacht hat irgendwann sollte man das doch checken wie man
paar comments zusammen fasst und so was die meisten haben keinen bock sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
aber dann soll das jetzt nicht der super krass hohe bezahlte konsultant sein oder dass das
nervt mich dann immer wenn es wenn es ein gebiet ist ich würde das ich würde das auch ich würde
das auch voraussetzen aber anscheinend kann man das nicht voraussetzen das sind so themen mit
denen von denen ich weiß ich kenne mich da ganz brauchbar aus ja ich mache das schon lange ich
setze mich da lange mit auseinander also ich habe da vielleicht auch ein bisschen vorsprung und ich
bin da sehr schnell genervt von von ultra noobs die nichts lernen wollen ich erkläre die sachen das
ist gar kein ding aber wenn einer zum zehnten mal wegen dem gleichen schitt zu mir kommt geht
mir das mega auf den sack thema auch noch nicht aber mir hilft es immer zu realisieren dass andere
software entwickler darunter auch leiden als tipp kann ich die anderen blicken wahrscheinlich
noch weniger durch erfolge zu konzentrieren mehr mit anderen software entwicklern zusammen zu
arbeiten und auch dir klar zu machen dass du nicht alles wissen kannst und es ist auch übrigens
vollkommen ok wenn man sagt man hat keine ahnung davon es sollte jetzt vielleicht nicht das
kernthema sein für das man hauptsächlich eingestellt wurde das wäre vielleicht nicht
so gut aber du kannst nicht alles wissen also kann sich jedes tool kennen alle parameter wissen und
mit jeder technologie da irgendwie und point sein das funktioniert nicht die leute erwarten das
auch gar nicht man denkt oftmals dass die leute das erwarten die leute fragen dich einfach nur
weil die denken du bist jemand der eigentlich ahnung von sagen wir mal von von linux thematiken
hat und die fragen dich halt einfach in der hoffnung du weißt es aber die erwarten nicht
wirklich von dir dass du dass du das alles weiß die fragen dich weil du vielleicht ihnen in der
vergangenheit schon öfters mal helfen konntest fragen dich dann was und dann kannst du ja sagen
also damit habe ich nichts gemacht und vielleicht weißt du ja jemanden sie fragen können der damit
schon was gemacht hat das reicht ihnen schon ja ok und wenn du wirklich irgendwelche leute hast die
dir dann blöd kommen von wegen mit ja aber du musst das doch wissen muss gar nichts musst du wissen
der müsste es eigentlich vielleicht auch wissen weil es eher zu seinen aufgabengebieten gehört
also das die also es kommt eigentlich so gut wie nie vor dass dann einer wirklich blöd kommt wenn
du sagst nee weiß ich nicht wie gesagt es sollte jetzt vielleicht nicht dein t dein kernthemen
gebiet sein ja also wenn du wenn du admin bist und nicht weiß wie du dich per ssh verbindest ist
das vielleicht nicht so toll aber dass du nicht jeden parameter aus dem kopf wissen kannst
letztendlich kochen wir alle nur mit wasser ja so ist es du machst dich bestimmt besser als du
denkst das muss man das muss man sich öfters mal vergegenwärtigen es kochen alle nur mit wasser
übrigens microsoft facebook google und sonst wie alle kochen sie nur mit wasser und gerade dort
wo es besonders toll aussieht von außen die kochen auch nur mit wasser das wenn das gefühl
hast besser als software wahren zu wollen die frage ist ja die drei tips aus diesem video empfehlen
moin leute die frage ist ja ob entwickler bei google die an google programmieren auch googlen
dabei
talks to hogwarts legacy oder wirst du streamen nein ich werde es nicht streamen und ich werde es
auch nicht kaufen weil mich harry potter überhaupt so gar nicht null interessiert ich habe nach
diesem ganzen twitter kreis gewichse der letzten tage
ein bisschen den den reflex verspürt es mir so als trotzreaktion zu kaufen einfach nur so weil
ich mir gedacht habe wie könnte man das jetzt mal die leute ein bisschen abfacken aber letztendlich
wäre das ja doppelt bescheuert dann würde ich irgendwas kaufen nur um andere abzufacken was
ich selbst gar nicht spielen will und mich das franchise auch null interessiert also das
wäre noch bescheuert bei bingen die wegen chat gpt durchaus möglich dann kommt google und
blockt wahrscheinlich bing ja ok das ist natürlich auch lost ja auf twitter stream ja dann geht es
richtig zur sache die berufsschule hat es geplogged wirklich chat gpt
ja kann schon sein ich meine die machen ja auch software für meck zum beispiel studio
for meck wobei ich seriously keine ahnung habe wer visual studio for meck verwendet
wenn ich kostplattform ist die scharp dotnet entwicklung machen will dann mit rider was
besser ist als wichita zu meiner ansicht nach besser ist als wichita studio bestimmt auch
besser als wichita studio for meck und wenn ich es nur machen will dann kann ich einfach
kostenloses visual studio verwenden also keine ahnung warum es das überhaupt gibt aber microsoft
wird es wissen wieso gibt es visual studio for meck aber nicht für linux oder microsoft
weil microsoft linux generell ziemlich am arsch vorbeigeht außer außer dort wo sie
geld verdienen können natürlich was ja auch jetzt nicht irgendwie verwerflich ist ja mit
wsl oder msql für für linux und solche geschichten ja zwicks geht mir genauso geht mir genau das
ist eigentlich das was mir am meisten geht aber guckt euch mal guckt euch maui an maui
unterstützt auch kein linux desktop allerdings finde ich das nicht schlimm weil maui ist
eh shit ich würde nix in maui machen keine desktop anwendung keine mobile apps nix ja
benchmark dotnet ist poc benchmark dotnet ist top
das kann ich mittlerweile mit plug-in auch weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher sind ob das
benchmark das kann auch irgendwelche pdf reports generieren wenn die gerne die sachen ausdrucken
willst aber ich muss sagen ich habe ich bin ja kein hauptberuflicher software entwickler
auch wenn wir hier relativ viel software entwicklung im stream machen also ich habe noch nie einen
wirklich großen dotnet projekten mit massig entwicklern zusammengearbeitet also das hat
er doch gerade gelesen im video das buch also ich habe das nicht gelesen aber ich würde
nach amazon bewertung gehen das taugt oder nicht aber die einfachste variante sind wir
uns ja alle einig ist einfach keine fehler machen beim programmieren dann muss man nicht
dokumentieren und man muss auch nicht testen weil das funktioniert einfach immer alles
wie ist der neue rechner bis jetzt top habe ich jetzt seit december im einsatz ich habe
so gut wie nichts drauf gespielt was die leistung brauchen würde außer 15 jahre alte
16 jahre alte 20 jahre alte mmos oder so ja 20 jahre alte mmos wtf so alt ist das schon
meine güte kann man sich gar nicht richtig vorstellen man 20 jahre altes mmo fack alter
bin ich alter na zumindest ich habe kaum was drauf gespielt was die krasse leistung eigentlich
bräuchte das einzige das einzige was ich gespielt habe bisschen leistung braucht es den neuesten
patchbettel viel 20 42 die ansicht im task manager die ist pogu kommt mal hier ja das
natürlich nice so was so eine ansicht hattest du früher nur auf irgendeiner fetten kiste
im rechenzentrum ja guck mal guck mal wie das aussieht guck mal wie das aussieht 9,9
von 63,8 gigabyte belegt ich muss mehr browser tabs aufmachen 40 90 ja man sollte das nehmen
was für die jeweilige anwendung sinn macht man muss nicht alles super in microservices
aufsplitten um der um der microservices willen und alles unglaublich kompliziert machen
aber je nachdem was man vor hat was man davon vielleicht in der cloud betreiben will wie
man was skalieren möchte je nach user anzahl load was auch immer kann es sinn machen also
da muss ich angucken was man machen will das kann man pauschal überhaupt nicht sagen
wenn ich glück habe oder wenn ich bock drauf habe dann gibt es eine ordentliche github
read me und das wars guck mal also das ist das ist schon ausgesprochen für meine verhältnisse
ist das schon ausgesprochen viel dokumentation ja mehr gibt es nicht
mal manchmal habe ich im source code noch ein paar hinweise drinne stehen wo ich wo ich
mir gedanken mache dass ich das vielleicht in einem monat selbst noch checken manchmal
habe ich ein paar sachen drin stehen warum ich da an manchen stellen was gemacht aber
auch nicht so oft github read me fertig aus reicht wie ist der bluetooth empfang ich habe
die meistzeit den controller per usb angeschlossen gehabt ich habe mal den ps4 controller probiert
der ging eigentlich ohne probleme ich war aber auch nicht wirklich weit weg
das ich war auch nicht weit weg von also keine ahnung wenn ich damit probleme habe kaufe
ich mir irgend so ein billing usb usb bluetooth dongel und fertig du guckst ja auf einem über
tag 3 ja das coole ist ja gut 8g ram wäre mir ein bisschen wenig das ist ungefähr der
rechner den ich vor 10 jahren zusammengebaut habe das ist ungefähr den rechner den ich
gebaut habe als ich als ich hier ins haus eingezogen bin 2013
hallo jungs exzellent hallo jungs und mädels ja die youtube die youtube suche funktioniert
mal wieder richtig richtig gut da ist er doch mein rechner was ist drin ausgepackt genau
das ist ungefähr das was du auch hast den baro so ungefähr ungefähr von der von der
leistung ja und der wobei der schon 16 g ram hatte
so ungefähr ungefähr kommt das aufs gleiche raus ja gut readme template ja also ich muss
sagen ich fand das readme sehr schick von unserem von unserem modge auf github von
seinem von seinem wacom ladenprojekt high IQ modge modge check guck mal so sieht sein
readme aus finde ich richtig schick sogar mit screenshots und und wichtig emojis emojis
ist the way the way to go ist glaube ich der normalfall dass man keine 4 bis 5k rumliegen
hat um sich neuen rechner zu kaufen es sei denn man macht es wie ich sich einfach jahrelang
nix kaufen oder halt irgendwann rechner du hast level 10 gepackt wo sind wir gestern
stehen geblieben bei level 9 glaube ich ja dann machen wir machen wir die tage weiter
mit den restlichen übungen mal gucken wie wir mal gucken wie ich mich bei den schweren
schlage bisher ging es ja eigentlich ganz gut ja 64 g ram muss sein leute ich habe übrigens
64 g ram in dem neuen rechner nicht weil es jetzt irgendwie unbedingt erforderlich ist
also mit 32 g kommt man auch ohne probleme aus ich habe 64 g ram in dem neuen rechner
einzigen allein aus dem grund weil ich mehr ram haben wollte als im alten ernsthaft das
ist der einzige das ist der einzige grund warum ich warum ich 64 g ram drinnen habe
weil ich mehr ram haben wollte als im alten rechner rauchen tut man es nicht wirklich
tarifberater tarifberater gehalt und provision was verdient ein verkäufer im einzelhandel
oder hat man ja sehr viel endkunden kontakt da hätte ich mal absolut zu null so abso gar
nicht so negativ bock drauf das zu machen gucken wir uns mal was der kundenberater
minus ja minus infinity bock hätte ich da ein bisschen an wie der friseur da wobei
das stimmt nicht der fabian redet ja überhaupt nicht so so extrem sexisch also macht jetzt
er wechselt gerade sind wir versuchen auch immer mal ein bisschen lockeren spruch zu
lassen das geld was ich hier verdiene ist für mein und mein krasser bad alter verhältnisse
schon ein sehr gutes gehalt aus so aus so gedreht und so da braucht da bestimmt ein
bisschen für jeden tag dass es so dass er so steht wie eine eins mein name ist ich bin
33 jahre alt und bin mobilfunkberater in kämmnitz
das sehe ich mich das sehe ich mich am besten am besten finde ich also von von diesen ganzen
sprüchen unsere rede wendung im osten also eine sache ist mir aufgefallen was alle was
alle leute aus dem osten sagen diese die sagen nicht die sagen zustimmung zustimmung ist da
nicht yo oder so die sagen nö ich kann es gar nicht nachmachen nö nö das sagen total
viele das scheint da so unser umgangs umgangssprache zu nö ja nö
dafür sind die miener sehr günstig ich gehe die freiwerker verjahle jetzt mal besuchen
einfach mal so sagen wir termine abklappern heute und dann können immer die musik nicht
so laut machen mann wer mich denn diese beiträge immer ab alter sind wir so ein bisschen rett
kunde kunde kenne ich kunde kunde sagte fabian auch öfters das ist auch so kunde kunde
ist ist das ist so was das ist so was wie wie ich ich weiß ich opfer trifft nicht so
wirklich das ist das ist auch so so wie könnte man wie könnte man das hier übersetzen das
auch so ein spezieller typ halter das ist das auch ein kunde
trahntüte vielleicht so ein bisschen bisschen depp oder so geht er geht gerade nicht der key
von freiberg bin in das deute man mit guten morgen alles bin freiberg und dann
also mein job beinhaltet im endeffekt täglich tarifoptimierung von kunden speziell tarifoptimierung
nennt sich das so so der code ist abgelaufen ja tarifoptimierung bedeutet man erzählt den
leuten was sie neues brauchen und verkauft in neuen kram dass der tarifoptimierung ist
eine sehr positive umschreibung der ganzen sache mobilfunk dsl gas und strom
ich bin kaffee junkie also ich trinke am tau bestimmt 8 bis 10 tassen ich bin prinzipiell
in kämmen sich für ja leider und freiberg die filiale ist für mich immer noch so eine
herzensangelegenheit weil ich die letztes jahr im juni eröffnet hat deswegen bin ich öfter
da fehlt aber wieder die 15.000 euro kaffeemaschine bei wie bei dem anderen dude freiberg
um einfach auch hallo zu sagen vielleicht auch mal kundentermine wahrzunehmen die speziell
zu mir wollen moin das hat mir gemacht genau das war ja gab es damals diese probleme mit
dem anschluss hast du jetzt die 100.000 wir haben uns auf die 50er tausender die 50er
tausender hatten wir ja auch gemacht genau das läuft ja habt ihr eine preiserhöhung
bekommen ja wir bezahlen jetzt für januar februar 6 89 euro jetzt haben wir aber aktuell
die möglichkeit jetzt jetzt passt auf leute jetzt wird jetzt wird optimiert in strompreis
zu kriegen der unter den 40 cent ist sprich du bist noch günstiger ist nicht viel aber
es ist was was unter dem unter den 40 cent ist ja dafür zwei jahre vertragsbindung oder
irgendwie so zeug ja also macht jetzt der wechsel gerade sind wir haben unsere kundgehalt
und den anteil provisionen halt im endeffekt für jeden vermittelten tarif machen wir das
so dann quatscht du mit deinem freund und gute frage chat die acht tassen kaffee die
machen schon was aus den schönen nachmittag gerne was gut für sie das ist immer diese
aktive ansprache weil die kunden wissen es nicht weil die kunden beschäftigen sich mit
zwischenthemen nicht wir geben im endeffekt die postleitzahl angebenden verbrauch ein und
dann werden uns die stromanbieter angezeigt die wir zur verfügung haben mit dem günstigsten
preis und können vergleichen hey wo kommst du denn am günstigsten wo kommst du denn
an strom ich dachte eben ging es ums internet ach nee mobilfunk gas strom oder dsl ok ach
so verstehe die machen die die die machen verschiedene ok ok dann fast jetzt verstehe
ich das das ist gar nicht von einem speziellen anbieter das ist eher so eine art so eine
art vergleichsportal ach so ja ok ok dann dann ist optimierung auch in dem fall tatsächlich
weniger zu verstehen als irgendwas neues mit möglichst langer tarifbindung zu verkaufen
sondern wahrscheinlich wirklich zu gucken dass es irgendwie für die billige wird aber
selbstverständlich auch provision zu kassieren wegen der vermittlung am teuersten und suchen
natürlich für den kunden immer das beste raus ist das schlimm wenn ihr mit auf dem bild seid
morgen die profession wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht der endkunde bezahlen die profession wird
ja wahrscheinlich der anbieter bezahlen was dann letztendlich wieder umgelegt wird auf den
endkunde ja klar aber es ist nicht so als muss der was bezahlen wenn er dahin geht denke ich
jetzt einfach mal rate ich jetzt mal ich habe eine paus ist wenn ich es doch richtig sprechen
was denn der food nur mal was war das deutsch gerade wenn einer wohne mit der anderen wohne
in den fall ja die herausforderung ist schon tatsächlich auch neuguten ich muss mal kurz ich
muss mal kurz in mein mime board was hinzufügen was was mir was mir wirklich fehlt noch wobei
ich habe ja den eigentlich ich habe den erreicht ja ich wollte diesen diesen typ ich weiß nicht
wie dieses mime heißt wisst ihr das wo dieser typ so so so guckt so ein bisschen wie die katze
nur dass es ein mensch ist so so wie heißt dieser typ nein nein nein nein nicht der whiteboard typ
dass ein bisschen den kopf schräg macht und dann macht keine an man kann mime sehr schlecht
beschreiben das muss man sagen weil die branche ist riesengroß die betreut das wohnen die haben
den typ ja genau den mein ich wusste noch der chat du mime den typ den typ meine ich du wie
schreibt man das den typ meine ich aber wir haben die katze das reicht das ist schön
wissen sie dass 100 prozentig dass der telefonanschluss ist also die 100 also 20 prozent dann würde ich sie
einfach mal darum bitten sich da wirklich noch mal zu 100 prozentig kundig zu machen ob dort
wirklich der telefonanschluss anliegt na ja ein termin tschüss seine mama hat das problem
sie sieht jetzt ein betreutes wohnen und möchte gerne einfach das telefon mit der festnummer
auch ins betreute wohnen mitnehmen so dass sie auch erreichbar ist aber hier seid die frage
beim betreuten wohnen ob man es wirklich 100 prozentig mitnehmen kann erst bei exzellente
musik im hintergrund also hier in diesem ort gibt es nirgends woanders freiberger eierschecke
das ist eigentlich ganz geil freiberger eierschecke na mein guter pass mal auf du bist aber jetzt in
der kundversorgung hast du nicht so lange zeit den strom zu wechseln du musst du nicht kommen wir
können das auch alles auf den digitalen weg machen also wie gesagt eine sache von fünf minuten
also eins muss man ihm ja lassen er scheint keine probleme haben probleme zu haben mit
endkunden kontakt ich habe eher den eindruck dass gefällt ihm auch noch und macht dem spaß das ist
immer so unterschiedlich können die leute sein für mich wäre das der pure horror das machen zu
müssen ich meine irgendwo gehen die acht tassen kaffee auch hin deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen hippelig aber dem scheint es ja zu gefallen ich komme ein geht es dir denn wie
geht es dir denn damit damit was sagt man darauf sollte ich jetzt ehrlich antworten oder nicht frisch
siehst du aus ich will aber erst noch zu versorgen das ist ein süßer frech aus frech was neues
telefon das sieht man ja sieben oder achtung das ist es immer in rosa na gut die frau spielt
jetzt erstmal keine rolle was wissen von iphone haben das soll nie werden kann man können die
leute nicht einfach auf geizhals gehen oder ins internet eingeben iphone 14 und sich den günstigsten
anbieter raussuchen muss man das seriously irgendwo vor ort in den lagen jeder wie er will
meinetwegen aber ich verstehe es bloß nicht der geht jetzt im endeffekt auch auf so eine
vergleichsseite und das ist auch immer ein sehr schöner moment ist wenn du wirklich
persönliche positive bewertung bei google bekommst also wurde auch namentlich erwähnt
jetzt gibt es dicke professionen der hat für ein neues iphone gleich neuen vertrag
abgeschlossen sich das richtig ja okay dann ist kein wunder ja weil es günstig ist
das sehe ich dich weil es günstig ist top erklärung ich bin schon so ein bisschen
hübelig also ich denke das habt ihr mitbekommen zu viel kaffee ich versuche auch immer mal
ein bisschen lockeren spruch zu lassen und so ist nie mal eine verkaufsstrategie ist das was ich
weiß ich das einfach will weil ich prinzipiell andere leben auch interessant finde ich interessieren
andere leben also andere leben ist jetzt vielleicht ein doofer ausdruck ich überfahre nicht einfach
absichtlich leute und finde es geil aber mich interessieren andere leute und denen ihre geschichte
so überhaupt nicht genau und umsatz machen ich habe eine wirkliche reife habe dann im endeffekt
eine ausbildung angefangen zum alten pflege haben musste die allerdings kurz vor prüfung
abbrechen aufgrund ja genau also das war tatsächlich wirklich der stress weil teilweise dienstpläne hat
es mit 40 tage durcharbeiten und irgendwann funktioniert man nur noch körperlich die
müssen sich nicht wundern dass sie dass das keiner machen will also ganz ehrlich ich kann
jeden verstehen der kein bock hat pflege oder ins krankenhaus zu gehen es gibt ja genug leute
die ein bisschen sozial veranlagt sind und das eigentlich gerne machen würden
aber selbst die haben schon oftmals kein bock mehr weil es einfach zu heftig ist aber
kopftechnisch nicht und man wird so immer träger geworden immer müder kam aus dem wett gekommen
dann gesagt ich trenne mich von diesem job und das war das beste was ich machen konnte so schade
so ist weil es ein schöner beruf eigentlich ist und ich brauchte aber noch mal irgendeine
ausbildung habe dann meine kaufmännische ausbildung noch gemacht also kaufmann im
einzelhandel allerdings im fotofach handel also komplett andere branche hat dadurch auch die
liebe zur fotografie bekommen und habe dann nach meiner ausbildung tatsächlich mich selbstständig
gemacht als fotograf habe es einfach gewagt ist aber irgendwann gescheitert ist halt so kann ich
alles klappen siehst du siehst du laut ich finde das genau richtig wenn er hat das probiert es kann
nicht alles klappen und das ist halt auch einfach die realität wichtig ist jetzt nur dass er nicht
dass er nicht sagt so nach dem motto alter ich bin komplett versager kriegt nie wieder was hin
oder irgendwie voll deprimiert nur noch durch leben geht dass das ist die realität ist viele
der sachen die die versucht wird klappen erst mal nicht und das ist auch das was mir bei diesen
ganzen youtube ich erzähle euch jetzt wie es reich wie reich werdet videos immer so so fragwürdig
finde die tun ja fast so als reicht es komplett aus wenn du dir einfach nur selbst einredest du
kannst nicht scheitern und bist der größte auf der welt du musst keine ahnung haben von irgendwas
du musst nichts können du musst eigentlich nur das krasse mindset haben du musst dich einfach
nur geil finden das ist das alle ich bezweifle gar nicht dass sich geil finden entscheidend zum
erfolg beitragen kann mit sicherheit aber das alleine reicht halt auch nicht und den einen in
den einzigen leuten den das was bringt sind dann die typen die irgendwelche whatsapp gruppen und
ausbildungs und und seminare und sowas anbieten dafür so nach dem motto du brauchst nur das
richtige crying set mindset und und dann ist alles gut ja klar natürlich
ja damals ein kredit aufgenommen damals meine selbstständigkeit noch irgendwann
war halt die auftragslage sehr schlecht geworden den kredit bezahlt jetzt noch monatlich noch
ab aber eigentlich ist es ein interessierter damit für mich zu sein hätte er mal hätte
er meine gmbh gemacht und wer pleite gegangen ist gut ja so ich muss ein oder zwei andere
sachen noch checken dann habe ich noch einen termin der händchenübergabe ansonsten steht
tatsächlich heute in chemnitz aktuell nicht so viel an erst mal eine runde kaffee gehen wird
wer schon so dass ich gerne noch ausbilderschein machen würde also ich würde gerne ausbilden
wollen also wirklich auch mal jemanden frisch aus der schule hier in den laden rein stellen
aber eins muss man sagen er macht einen äußerst motivierten eindruck das muss man ihm mal lassen
begleiten und ins berufsleben mit rein zu schubsen wir haben so ein kleines paketshop noch aber
prinzipiell gesehen versucht man natürlich schon auch so als zwischen paketshop könnten auch
normale kunden so nach dem motto ja hier ist ihr paket was haben sie so für internetanschluss
ach wie nur dsl nur dsl 16k das ist doch bei ihnen doch hier sicherlich schon fast gigabit
möglich wollen wir nicht mal kurz gucken und dann hat er die leute an der angel eigentlich
keine schlechte kombination
so computer ausmachen ist aus danke tschau und türe am besten fall zuschließen heute
sitz ich richtig sitz alles ja mein brudergehalt ist 2080 euro dazu kommt eine provision und da
bin ich wirklich nicht so viel im gesamten meistens zwischen 1900 und 2000 euro netto
und das lohnt sich tatsächlich für mich schon ok es ist es ist es ist der osten es ist der
osten aber es ist halt insgesamt echt nicht so die so krass jetzt aber im osten ist es
wahrscheinlich ganz ok ich kann es schlechte einschätzen ost ostdeutschland gehälter
eigentlich ganz gut davon leben eigentlich nicht beschweren also wenn ich mal zeit habe
komm ich mal rum oder wenn sie sagt ja oder braucht mich jetzt mal aus grund xy muss
sie halt nicht mal was berufliche sein kann auch gerne was private sein bin ich gerne da
dafür geht ja auch mal feiern oder einfach auch mal so privat
das ist cool ich meine es hat schon was wenn du überall am start bist der macht ja der
labert die alle an so nach dem motto hier den typ an der bar und wollen wir mal gucken
wegen deinem telefon der verkauft wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich der putzfrau wenn er wenn er
aufs klo geht noch nebenbei in vertrag oder so was kommen sie bei uns mal im laden vorbei
wir haben eine ganz tolle tarife da sparen sie massig geld der ist glaube ich einfach
so also das driften ganz schnell ins private über ja ich bin eigentlich derjenige der
viel über und umsatz hier und vertrag da da sehe ich mich das geld was ich hier verdiene
ist für meiner meinung nach sachsen verhältnisse schon sehr gutes gehalt ich muss nicht überlegen
ob ich mir heute was teures mal zu essen kaufen oder essen gehe oder mal was ich unter
disko mal lassen mit eintritt und eintritt rum und dran
versicherung vier ist halt ist halt im osten ist es halt einfach billiger vieles drumherum
kommst du auch mit 1850 euro netto aus
mobilfunkberater ich kann euch einmal den wirtschaftsprüfer empfehlen und den schulleiter
und lassen abo da und bis dahin tschau kakao okay alles klar jedes vierte ich kann aber
mir gut vorstellen dass der viel verkauft der hat so eine art und weise ansicht ich
glaube mit dem reden die leute gerne ich glaube der ist auch sehr beliebt bei rentnern
und omas und sowas die sagen auch ja da gehen wir wieder bei dem netten jungen mann von
tarif guru vorbei und lassen uns das 100 pro ich glaube der macht seinen job da echt gut
ja genauso baro so sieht aus das sieht aus als ist er happy dabei als macht es ihm spaß
als kommt er super über die runden was willst du mehr
oder tätowiert oder nicht der friseur ist ja mittlerweile auch ich meine ihr habt ja
wahrscheinlich in den letzten jahren nicht viel von ihm mitgekriegt der friseur ist ja
auch mittlerweile glaube von kopf bis fuß gut kopf weiß ich nicht aber von von unterhalb
kopf bis fuß auch überall tätowiert ich glaube ich glaube sogar der fabian hat zwischenzeitlich
oder macht er noch ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher hat sogar in so in in einem studio gearbeitet
und was ich auch gehört habe ist dass er irgendwelche videos für irgendwelche fitness studios in
dresden jetzt wohl macht davon habe ich aber das habe ich schon habe ich nur hören sagen
ja als unterwäsche model auch ja er kommt wenn einer als unterwäsche model durchgeht
dann der fabian der macht doch style technisch was her
physik studieren so ist das wirklich ohne physik studieren habe ich ich studiere gar
nichts mehr aber physik studieren muss echt nicht sein wobei ich an sich viele thematik
ich gucke gerne videos darüber aber auf studieren hätte ich ernsthaft überhaupt kein bock das
ist eines der schwersten und anstrengendste studium was du machen kannst
und ihr kennt mich ich vermeide gerne anstrengung
anstrengung ist nicht nicht im scope
wie gesagt ich werde nichts mehr studieren
macht auch gar warum sollte ich was studieren ich verdiene ich verdiene gut gut kohle auch
ohne irgendwie studiert zu haben und das einzige warum ich studieren
könnte warum warum es eventuell sinnvoll wäre ist wenn ich selbst so den andrieb hätte so
nach dem motto alter ich will das für mich jetzt irgendwie noch mal machen oder so ok das
wäre was anderes aber für alles andere müsste ich nicht machen wieso immer ausgelockt bei youtube
weil das mein streaming account ist mir bin ich nirgendswo eingelockt damit ich nichts leake
machst du hast das falsche mindset möglich hat die frage wird definiert was ein gutes und ein
schlechtes mindset ist mein mindset ist so viel arbeiten dass man genug geld hat dass man möglichst
viel das machen kann worauf man bock hat das ist mein mindset du möchtest das weil du dann immer
dokter genannt wirst ja dann musst du aber dann musst du aber das mal überlegen moment moment
du musst dein bachelor master und dann doktor machen und so eine doktor promovierung wie nennt
sich das dissertation promotion ok das dauert ja auch irgendwie drei jahre oder so was wenn
du da brauchst du in den thema brauchst du das begleitet das ist alles äußerst anstrengend und
sehr zeitintensiv und natürlich muss man auch was im kopf haben dafür ich weiß nicht was was
ich glaube die größten erfolge die der chain war vorzuweisen hat ist schon der fünfte twitch
account weil er überall gebannt ist oder sowas wobei du hast du hast den account schon erstaunlich
lange das stimmt was nicht ich interessiere mich für quantenphysik soweit dass ich mir
gerne videos angucke auf youtube zu der thematik es zu studieren und tatsächlich mir mathematische
theorien im detail dazu anzugucken unser das ist mit sand schon wieder zu anstrengend sei ich ganz
einfach weil ich der erste mit meinem nachnamen sein will der den bachelor gemacht hat das
du so einen ausgefallenen nachnamen dass noch niemand der einen nachnamen hat wie du
ein bachelor gemacht hat vorher weißt du das habe ich mein eigenes video der erste in der
familie ok das ergibt natürlich das ergibt natürlich schon eher sinn ok dass das verstehe
ja da habe ich da habe ich schon video zu gemacht die sache ist die ich habe angefangen mit mit der
ganzen thematik noch bevor es dafür einen namen gab also mit server automatisierung konfig
management versionsverwaltung release management solche geschichten da habe ich angefangen da
gab es da gab es das wort noch gar nicht dafür damals gab es übrigens das wort influencer für
leute die youtube und twitch waren auch noch nicht und nachdem ich das die ganze zeit schon
gemacht habe gab es dann irgendwann halt auch mal einen namen dafür ich habe es ok leute ich
will nicht so weit gehen dass ich es erfunden habe viele leute haben damals schon sachen gemacht die
man heute in diesem themengebiet ver verortet ja wir waren auf jeden fall früh dabei
stripes dankeschön für den sub 43 monate leute dazu kann man
bloß eindeutig sagen
high IQ abschlussarbeit es ist halt die frage das kann ich ja aber auch ohne abschluss ohne
ohne abschlussarbeit sagen das einfach nur wenn man sagt wir machen jetzt der fox continuous
integration delivery ohne ohne das richtig umzusetzen dass es dann nicht die produktivität
erhöht also muss das ordentlich machen und das muss ist die abläufe müssen das ist das aller
wichtigste die abläufe müssen zu den mehrweiligen unternehmen auch passen und nicht alle dagegen
arbeiten pauschal es gibt ja also ich glaube dass diese aussage von dir kein klares ja das
kannst du glaube ich auf nahezu alle sachen beziehen weil es gibt kaum was was wirklich
also genau 0 prozent ist oder 100 prozent also selbst wenn ich jetzt in frankfurt vom
messeturm springen würde überlebe ich das ja nein na gut er nicht aber es ist nicht
0 prozent es ist vielleicht ziemlich nah an 0 prozent aber es ist nicht 0 prozent also
es gibt es gibt ganz wenige sachen die wirklich ganz ganz klar als als 100 oder 0 also es
komplett richtig komplett falsch beantwortet werden können das allermeiste ist relativ
sicher so oder relativ unwahrscheinlich so aber so richtig 100 prozentig kann man es
auch schlecht sagen bei ganz bei den überwiegenden teil der sachen
wenn man es nicht richtig macht beziehungsweise irgendwelche sachen bei der implementierung
verkackt dann natürlich dass das ist ja auch der alltag in vielen unternehmen dass das
eine gesagt wird aber dann das andere gemacht wird oder zumindest nicht das richtige gemacht
wird um das was man eigentlich angekündigt hat positiv so zu unterstützen dass die leute
es auch benutzen
der fob ist kein zähes thema das ist einfach nur ein riesiger sammeln begriff für 30
milliarden verschiedene themen
du bist safe nach einem jahr weg solange das safe nach safe machst das alles gut das
ist ein neuer trend den ich gesehen habe wo mich auch etwas verwirrt und zwar also dieser
trend zur richtung wir machen jetzt alles full stack ist ja auch so ein ding was die
letzten jahre übergibt gut ich meine ganze it abteilung bedeutet also full stack bedeutet
nicht eine ganze it abteilung aber es gibt einen trend den ich irgendwie ein bisschen
merkwürdig finde und zwar so diesen haben wir das letztlich sogar in irgendeiner stellenanzeige
gesehen so dieses you build it you run it ich denke mir halt ja es ist sinnvoll auch
als entwickler über den tellerrand raus zu gucken worauf läuft denn die anwendung sich
ein bisschen mit mit mit servan auseinanderzusetzen mit linux auseinanderzusetzen genauso jemand
der hauptsächlich im admin umfeld unterwegs ist sich vielleicht auch mal anzugucken ok
wie funktionieren unsere anwendungen und sowas in der richtung das finde ich das finde
ich sinnvoll ja aber zu einem entwickler zu sagen du hast das jetzt gebaut du sollst
jetzt gefälligst auch betreiben das geht höchstens das geht höchstens wenn es so
eine komplette fertige plattform dafür gibt ja zum beispiel irgendein aks asia kubernetes
service wo alles im vorfeld schon fertig eingerichtet ist dass dieses you run it sich nur noch darauf
bezieht die erstellen irgendwie einen docker file oder die erstellen irgendwie in den deployment
jammeln oder sonst was pushen das und das läuft dann ist das ok aber so dieses ganze
betriebssache drum herum da würde ich sagen das muss den entwickler eigentlich auch nicht
noch zusätzlich können genauso wie in ordentlicher admin jetzt nicht zwangsläufig der der der
tollste frontend entwickler oder cobalt programmierer für ein host sein muss es hatte schon seinen
grund dass die leute unterschiedliche schwerpunkte haben und dann quasi zwei zwei thematiken
zu nehmen die schon was miteinander zu tun haben recht weit auseinander zu auseinander
liegen zu sagen das machen die leute jetzt auch noch mit ja dann weiß ich nicht was
sie sich da immer vorstellen
ja kannst du machen das ist die zum bilder generieren ne crew für elektrik dankeschön
für den sub 18 monat hier poggers der katze geht es gut ja wobei wobei ich weiß nicht
inwieweit du was mitgekriegt hast das ist nicht mehr die originale katze die originale katze
gibt schon seit ein paar jahren nicht mehr die war aber auch schon ziemlich alt als
ich die gekriegt habe original katze fps also die die getigerte die gibt es nicht mehr
aus dem ersten video aktuell aktuell habe ich chico die heißt nicht die katzen hießen
nie katz fps meine aktuelle katze heißt chico den namen habe ich mir auch nicht ausgedacht
die hieß schon so als ich aus dem tierheim geholt habe doch ich weiß ist der name ganz
gut das behalten wir so am am witzigsten war der name also ich hatte ich hatte ja original
katze fps die kennt ihr ja noch aus den ersten paar videos ich habe doch mal moment ich habe
doch mal ein video gemacht ich habe da sieht man die doch alle doch das war übrigens gerade
die aktuelle hier das ist das ist chico hier ist der max warum spielt warum spielt es einfach
beim video ab ich habe da doch mal ein video zu gemacht es war irgendwas mit tierheim nichts
mit nichts mit x hamster
tierheim das ist länger her aber ja so viele videos haben ja nicht gemacht
so ist egal was ich sage also hier sieht man hier sieht man die alle das ist chico das
ist chico wo sie der meinung war sie muss jetzt auf die liegt bei mir gerade auf dem
kleiderschrank oben und angelt angelt da ein bisschen rum das ist das ist chico chico
sagt gehen wir weg gehen wir nicht auf den kicks achtung achtung achtung gehst du weg
mittlerweile ist chico ein bisschen dünner als da achtung achtung chico ich habe ich
habe immer spuren am armen ja meine hause hinten rum so also das das ist das ist chico
die kann die kann einem dann auch mal schon in den armen beißen oder in den armen kratzen
wenn man nicht aufpasst ja
jetzt hat sie irgendwas gesehen irgendwas irgendwas gesehen und weg so das ist original
katz fps das ist das ist original katz fps die haben wir auch als emote die haben wir
auch als emote irgendwo hier wupp wupp pet 2 das ist original katz fps die war aber schon
ziemlich alt als ich die gekriegt habe die habe ich vom nachbar der nachbar ist gestorben
damals und die katze stand stand also die verwandten von ihm haben sich ein bisschen
drum gekümmert aber die stand dann öfters morgens im hof und hat rumgemaut und dann
habe ich dann irgendwann gesagt komm komm komm nur einfach mal rüber hab es ein bisschen
gefüttert und dann ist den tag später bei mir eingezogen und wollte nicht mal aus dem
haus raus hier ist gut hier ist gut das ist das ist original original katze katz fps und
jetzt kommt kommt noch eine die war zwischen original katz fps und und schicko war das
eine wurscht man das ist ja habe ich schon ganz vergessen wie dick die eigentlich gewesen
ist man das ist barbie die hieß seriously die hieß barbie das den namen habe ich mir
auch nicht ausgedacht aber von allen drei katzen sieht die mit abstand am wenigsten
nach barbie aus diese katze ja wirklich also mit bar und das ist auch die einzige katze
die ich hatte die gerne fernseh geguckt hat ich konnte der auf dem fernseh es gibt ja
youtube videos mittlerweile extra für katzen und so was die hat sich am liebsten zu erdhörnchen
und so was angeguckt fische vögel erdhörnchen die saß den ganzen tag vom fernseh wenn du
sie gelassen hast und hat und hat so katzen videos clips geguckt
die finde ich finde das super spannend
ne schicko macht keinen dreck die war schon dick die war schon dick
es war schon eine dicke wurscht ja guck sowas sowas hat die sich immer angeguckt sowas
hat die sich immer angeguckt irgendwelche komischen was sind das erdhörnchen oder sowas
auf der wiese furchtbar furchtbar spannend
da hat sich schicko versteckt ja gut also das sind die drei katzen die ich die letzten
jahre über hatte
also ich muss sagen katze fps war eindeutig die fotogeneste katze jetzt in der posi vielleicht
nicht aber der hat so das gefühl wenn du das handy rausgeholt hast die hat sogar gepost
fürs handy
erfahrung würde ich nicht sagen ich habe über die letzten jahre über den ein oder
anderen judemikurs mal gekauft aber nicht wirklich viele und ich mir fällt es auch gerade
schwer überhaupt mich daran zu erinnern welcher das war
kann es dir gar nicht sagen also ich kenne die seite ich weiß es gar nicht mehr
keine ahnung
ok komm eine sache können wir uns mal angucken dann muss ich was futtern wobei oder gehe
ich jetzt war ich bin 3 30 on ich habe ja heute schon eine halbe stunde früher angefangen
ich bin jetzt drei stunden 30 und das reicht wir sind jetzt alle wach ich mache mir jetzt
was zu essen dann mache ich mmo kreisel kreit oder wenn mmo kreisel kreit nicht geht dann
gehe ich gehe bin ich heute mittag noch mal und vielleicht machen wir wieder passo war
glücklich bis der leute wir sehen uns machts gut zu